I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Merry, merry Christmas. Merry, merry Christmas. It's Christmas on The Office again. Well, someone showed up very festive. That's right. It's a Benihana Christmas. Well, I think Angela Martin would let you know it's a Nutcracker Christmas. Oh, wow. Mm-hmm. Oh, wow, you're already going there. I am, lady. I am here. The Party Planning Committee has
arrived. Well, we'll talk about that. Guys, this is Season 3, Episode 10, written by Jen Solada, directed by Harold Ramis, a Benihana Christmas. And this is an hour-long episode. Yeah. So buckle in. It's going to be a super-sized episode of Office, ladies. And we have some exciting news. We have two special guests this week, Rashida Jones and writer Jen Solada. So much fun. And both of these ladies will be joining us for interviews during the episode. Well, Jenna, how about giving us a summary? Okay. It is Christmas at Dunder Mifflin. Carol breaks up with Michael the day of the Christmas party after Michael photoshopped himself under her family Christmas card. He put his face on her ex-husband's face from a family ski
trip and sent it out to people. Yeah. Oh, Michael. Well, Andy suggests he and some of the guys take Michael to Benihana to cheer him up. Meanwhile, Angela kicks Karen out of the Party Planning Committee. So Pam and Karen band together and start the committee to plan parties. We're going to have some dueling holiday parties. Oh, she should have had better ideas. Oh, boy. You, you are in it to win it today. And I came to play. I came to play. Well, later, Michael and the boys come back from Benihana with dates just in time for the two parties to merge. And we end with everyone singing their hearts out to karaoke. All right. Fast fact number one, Harold Ramis. Harold Ramis. I mean, Jenna, my whole childhood
were his movies. Legend. I was so giddy, nervous, excited to work with him. I mean, meatballs, caddyshack, ghostbusters, ghostbusters too. Groundhog day for flippin' sake. Stripes. Stripes. Oh my God. Yes. Stripes. Oh, also, Angela, he got his start at Chicago Second City. Yes. He's just like so talented. He's such a great writer as well, you guys. He's a writer, actor, director. He was just a comic legend, and I was in awe. Well, you know, he passed away in 2014. I just can't believe that I got to work with him, frankly. I know. Harold Ramis was just a teddy bear of a human. He just made you feel so comfortable, and he was so fun to talk to. And I have some great memories of him. We did a lot of conference
room scenes, obviously, in this episode. I was in the conference room quite a bit, right? Because my party versus Karen's and Pam's party. Yeah. And Harold was in the conference room with me, and we were just chatting, and he told this great story about how when kids would come trick-or-treating to his house, he lived in Illinois, he would put on the Ghostbusters uniform and answer the door in his Ghostbusters uniform. Yeah. He did that every year. I thought that was so delightful. It was the sweetest story. All right, let's move into FastFact number two, which I'm calling guest star breakdown. Okay. We got a breakdown. All of our guest stars, the Benny Hanna waitresses. The main waitress in the restaurant, Cindy,
is played by Brittany Ishibashi, who you might recognize from Runaways. She starred as Tina, as well as recurring roles on Hawaii Five-O and Grayson Frankie. But here is something very interesting about Brittany and me. What? Okay. Weirdly, both Brittany and I have had guest appearances on the TV shows Off-Center and Mismatch, but we were not in the same episode. So the office was the third project that she and I have both been in, but we've never shared a scene and we've never met. That's crazy. Our lives have sort of been intersecting. Brittany, am I going to meet you one day? You're on track to finally be in a project together at the same time on the same day, in the same scene. So Angela,
there are two more guest star waitresses. These are the waitresses that Michael and Andy bring back to the party. So first there is Amy, who is played by Cat On, and she's done just a ton of sketch comedy, stand up, funny or die. And then there is Michael's girlfriend Nikki, who is played by Kulap Velisok. Okay. I worked with Kulap on Hot Wives of Orlando. It was the show on Hulu. It's a really funny spoof of the Real Housewives and she was great in it. She's great in a lot of things, but that was a lot of fun to do. Well, lady, you know I loved that. I know. Okay. Fast fact number three, I got the scoop from Kentopedia on the Benihana location because we got a lot of fan questions
about it. I wanted to ask about that because I was wondering if it's the Benihanas in Encino. It sure is. I have been to that Benihanas and when I was rewatching this, the way you walk into the restaurant, you know, it's the same. And I was like, yeah, come on, that's Benihanas in Encino, California. Well, lady, we got some fan questions from Ashley Hildreth Rachel Martino, Hannah Holtman, Malia Holbrook, Abigail Hess, Rupinder Gossel and many others all asked, were the restaurant scenes filmed at an actual restaurant? How long did it have to be shut down? And is the chef at Benihana an actual Benihana chef or was it an actor? I'm going to say yes because he was too good with that knife. Yes. We will start there.
It was a real chef. We hired all of the chefs and all of the wait staff of the Encino Benihana to perform in the episode. And we also hired 78 background actors to play diners. We shut it down for a whole day. We rented out the entire place and it took about 12 hours to shoot those scenes. This is reminding me that we had a bigger budget because when in the past could we go in and be like, well, take the whole place. I mean, even Chili's was like an out of business boarded up. Yes. That's right. Restaurant. But this was like an actually like very successful restaurant that was always full of people. And we closed them down for a day. Wow. Wow. Well, and I did a deep dive on Benihana. And I'd like to give you now
the history of Benihana, the restaurant. Well, I didn't see that coming. So I'm, I'm ready. It's fascinating. This is from the Benihana website. And this is the first line from their description of the history of the Benihana restaurant. I'm going to quote it because it is fantastic. Quote, like any good story, the history of Benihana begins with the descendant of a samurai warrior and a small Tokyo coffee shop. Are you intrigued? I'm riveted. Okay. It's amazing. So this is what happened. So there's a couple in Tokyo, Yunusuke and Katzu. They started a coffee shop. And in order to set themselves apart, Yunusuke would bike over 20 miles to get real sugar to serve with the coffee in his shop. And this little detail
caused the shop to be a huge success. The name of their coffee shop was Benihana. All right. Cut to years later, the couple's son, Rocky, moves to the United States with dreams of opening a restaurant. He starts by going to night school to study restaurant management. And during the day, he sold ice cream on the streets of Harlem. But here's what he did. He put a little Japanese cocktail umbrella into the ice cream and this really set it apart. And eventually he earned $10,000, which he used to open his first Benihana restaurant, naming it after his parents' coffee shop in Tokyo. Well, that was adorable. Also, I'm a sucker for anything with a tiny umbrella in it. Give it to me. Any drink with a tiny
umbrella tastes better. It really does. Oh, yeah. I mean, that's a fact. I might have saved a few of those like from special occasions and they're in my kitchen. I don't doubt it. That is very you. I know. My husband's like, do we still need these? I mean, the little stick is broken. I'm like, no, don't throw it away. Okay. So there's more to the story. Okay. His first shop, which was on West 56th Street, it was exactly like how it is today. His vision was to have the tempanyaki grills set up in front of the customers with the chefs doing all the knife work. But it was, it was struggling at first until six months after they opened, the restaurant got a boost when a famous food critic came in and gave
the restaurant a fabulous review. Here's my favorite part of that. Can I tell you the name of the food critic, this famous food critic, like you wanted this person to come to your restaurant? Are you ready? Who? Clementine Paddleford. Oh, God. She sounds like a made up character in a Mary Poppins movie. She sounds like an improv game that I used to do when I did improv. Hey, guys, come on, we're going to do Clementine Paddleford. Let's do it. Right? I was like, what is happening? We're in a Disney film. I want, I want that. All right. Wait, wait, wait. There's just so many ways I want to use that name now. I want it to be a cocktail. I'll take a Clementine Paddleford, please. It comes with an umbrella.
And thank you, Clementine, for giving Benihana a rave review because the restaurant became a huge success and there are now over 70 Benihana restaurants in the United States, Caribbean and Central and South America. How about that? That is a really good one. And you know what? If your name is Clementine Paddleford, you are the best food critic in New York City. I mean, yes. I have a clear picture of this woman and her discerning food eating looks. Yeah. Oh, I need to see what she looks like. I only imagine her eating with like very tiny cutlery, like a tiny fork in a, right? Mm hmm. Why, why is that? All right, lady, thank you for indulging my deep dive on Benihana and Clementine Paddleford. Are you kidding?
I loved it. I need more Clementine Paddleford in my life. Same, same. But listen, should we move on now to our first interview? Yes. Okay, guys, we had such a fun storyline with Rashida Jones in this episode with the whole dueling Christmas parties and it was such a blast to shoot. We couldn't wait to reunite with her and talk all about it. So let's get to it, Sam. Run the interview with Rashida. I'm so happy to see your face. I know me too. This is so nice. I don't think the three of us have been, well, we're not in the same place, but we have at least been all talking to each other for like a decade. Oh, yeah. All in the same one place. Yeah. I think you're right. That makes me a little sad. Easy.
Isabel asked me a really random question the other day. She's like, mom, who of your friends have you been on a boat with? And I was like, well, I mean, Rashida and I went on an ocean conservation trip for Oceana. So we were on a lot of boats. Wait, a lot? I mean, we were like on a boat almost every day for a week in Belize. And so we were like clocking how many boats. And I'm like, well, technically maybe same boat, but a boat every day. That one dive that we took that day where there was like, it was like the 101 of the ocean. It was like sharks and eels and turtles. It was just the coolest. It was the coolest. I know. That was great. I miss all of that. I know. But yeah, I just thought it was just
like one of those questions your kid asks you. And then she's like, wait, you've never been on a boat with Jenna? I was like, no, Jenna, have you guys never been on a boat? We've never been on a boat. We've got some adventures, Jenna. You got it. You got to make that happen. You might have to do like a recording of your podcast on a boat. Oh, dear Lord, Rashida, look at our setup right now. Doesn't it sound good to imagine though? Yes. The future. Yes. One day we'll be boating and podcasting together. Oh, God, I love it. Well, we can't thank you enough for being here. We're so thrilled to have you. I'm so happy to be here. Well, Rashida, one question we always ask our guests is how did you come
to be on the office? I auditioned many, many times. I knew people socially before I joined the cast. And I went to college with Mike Schur. We were in a play together freshman year. Oh, man. Oh, it was a doozy. I would love to see what Mike Schur was like in college. He was the same. He was the same. Yeah. He was like floppy haired. I mean, he was a little less. I remember in our 20s, he got a fancy shirt for the first time and making fun of him for a really long time. So he was like Mike without any sort of socialization. And we were in a really bad farce together. And yeah, we became fast friends and we took a lot of classes together. Anyway, so I knew Mike and I came to know about the U.S. office
because he moved from New York and said, I got a job in LA and I'm going to write the U.S. office. And I was really mad at him as I think a lot of people were because we were like, how could you do that to the U.K. office? My favorite show. How could you even try? Yeah. And then it was in a lot of ways, you know, its own thing and even better and great. And, you know, but it was a big mountain, I'm sure, for you all to climb. Oh, yeah. My first reaction was like, no, no, no, no, no, it's perfect. It's perfect. Right. Right. And then of course I was like so thrilled, you know, when it was like Greg and such smart people in the writer's room. You guys had the benefit of playing characters that didn't
have a British counterpart. Like I was always worried, oh no, I don't want people to think that I stole my performance from Lucy Davis. Right. And so, but I had seen her performance and I'm sure it seeped in. How could it not? And also the lines were the same in the pilot. Right. But you guys had a big part, I think, of getting to influence your characters. Is that true on your part, Rashida? Angela's kind of talked about that before. There was some, remember there was some third point in a triangle that showed up in the U.K. office. There was like a love interest for Tim that came up, but a completely different like characterization of somebody who, you
know, who would be like a threat to that relationship. To end that other point, just to say that I auditioned many, many, many times and I remember having a distinct feeling then when I got to the point, Jenna, where you and I sat in a room and read lines together and then got to improv a little bit. Like everything just like made sense all of a sudden. You know, like it all, it was such a cool like counterpart. Like it made me feel like, oh, I really, like I feel like I really get this dynamic, you know. And I feel like you kind of got me the part in a lot of ways. No way. Yes. No, you did. I had that same experience with you in the room and it's very similar to when they paired
me up with John. I was like, oh, when I'm paired up with this person, I just turn into Pam. I think I read with two or three different people and Mike asked me, so what did you think? Who'd you like? And I just went on and on and on and on and on about you. And I was like, I mean, she was amazing. I told him all those things. She made it so easy to be Pam. And he was like, okay, noted. But he didn't say like, oh, she's my best friend from college. I can't wait to tell her. So he played it so cool. No. And by the way, with me too, like I wish if there were a time I really wanted a part and I had, I could like curry some favor with people I knew this was the time, but like
nobody would do anything for me because you know how Craig is too. I mean, he was like asking everybody he could not make up his mind. There was like another woman who was kind of trying to decide between us. I came in so many times. I waited for so long. Mike, you know, Mike is like ethical Mike. So he wasn't going to be like, I'm going to just, I'm going to gun for you. He was like, it has to be the right person for the part and everybody has to be on board. So like, it was torch, it was torturous. Like they really, really took me to the bitter end before I, before I got the call. I'm so glad you got the part.
It changed my whole career. Yeah. Yeah. I was like about to quit acting before I got the show. So it was, it was a big deal for me for Jen and I. This was the first time I had rewatched the whole Benny Hanna Christmas like all in one sitting. Yeah. I had seen little clips because you know, it's the little drummer boy and people like send me clips of me doing that, but I hadn't really sat down and watched it all. And what about you? Was this the first time you rewatched it? Yes. I hadn't seen it. I don't think since it aired and I was giggling so much. And like
a couple of things occurred to me. One was that we got that payoff, Jenna. Finally, like that thing that like came to life in the audition, I don't think it really got to really manifest until this episode, you know, because up to now we were kind of like rivals and like sniffing each other's butts. That sounds gross, but you know what I mean? If we were dogs, we would have been doing that. And this is the first time that like, I think the humanity in both characters recognized the mutual humanity in the other one and was like, you know what? Like it's Christmas and we work in this in these closed quarters. And also we have a common enemy in Angela.
So it was like, it just was easy for us to, to, to like, to, to be a team, which I thought that was really cool. I don't mean to toot our own horns, but I think we had amazing chemistry in this episode. I just, I mean, we are adorable. Can I say it? You can say it. You can say it. There could have been a spin off. That's all I, I just want to say. Say Pam and Karen Christmas special. Yes. I can tell you guys, we would hang out between scenes and I would just start cracking up
and just be with you guys. I'd be like, Hey, I'm hanging out. It's the girls. And then like on action, I had to be so mean to both of you. And then you like got to have this whole other hangout. It was hard. I know. Phyllis Phyllis really gets to emote how much she's like missing the other party. I wasn't able to, but that's how I felt. I know, I know, but it's good because it all plays out in the episode because we like, we joined forces. We did what we needed to do, which is just like teach you a lesson
and help you to stop being so controlling. And then you got to sing, you know? Oh God, I was terrified. I don't like singing front of people. You guys, that was hard. But God, I listen, I had to do it at that, in that wedding episode where to sing the police and I was so scared. Do you remember that episode? Whose wedding was it? Is that Phyllis's wedding? Phyllis's wedding. Yes. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
It is interesting time to watch these episodes again. You know, Jenna and I have talked about this a little bit. That was interesting for me to rewatch it now. How was it for you? I mean, listen, that was the second thing I was going to say is watching the off. I haven't watched the show since it aired. And, you know, I think so much of the show and so much of Michael and what works about Michael is this delicate balance between full cringe and like well-intentioned, loveable, like bad boss. And to watch it now in the current climate, like that balance feels different. It just feels so different. I mean, there's so much stuff. It's not, it's beyond cringe. It's like, wow. But it's also to me, like,
you know, I think there's so much conversation right now about what's acceptable, but also like in retrospect, what we're allowed to kind of partake in, you know, in a time where things were considered more acceptable, even if they weren't and they shouldn't be. I think it's good to have things that read really badly now and didn't read badly at the time because it is a mark of our progress. And it's also like the show resonates because Michael reminds people of their bosses and people they work with and maybe a little bit of themselves. And it's like really important that people see that like you have to measure up to the moment that you're in. So much of the show is like people putting up with like
his bad behavior and being like, oh my God. And now I think people feel armed at work to be like, you know what? I don't like the way you're talking about that person or that woman or that whatever. Like, I don't, that's not acceptable behavior anymore. And you could say something and feel empowered as like an employee to do that, you know. So it was super fascinating. I think a lot of times we on the show as characters, we would speak up by giving a look to camera or indicating our disapproval. But you're right. I think today we would speak up right to his face. Michael wouldn't have a job with that behavior though. It's one too many infractions, Michael. Geez. He's like a human resources nightmare.
And that's the funny thing too is that Toby is the enemy. Like Toby's trying to like he's sensitive and he's trying to take care of people and be tolerant. And like Michael hates him so much for it because he's killing his party. And like that this feels like like a relationship you couldn't even write today really, you know, one of the notes that Greg gave Steve when Steve was like starting to perform as Michael is that he saw the character as this guy who thinks maybe Jennifer Aniston might see this tape someday. Like, so to sort of play it like, right. And you I so see in Steve's performance how Michael Scott thinks he's an entertainer. He thinks he's funny and cutting edge and pushing boundaries.
And he's just so inappropriate. But I, I see his performance in a different way knowing that note from Greg. Totally. Well, also because, you know, there's a conversation around who is entitled to push the boundaries. And I think that entertainers feel like they can in a way that normal people can't. And so it would make sense that like Michael would think he's one of those entertainers and not one of those normal people, you know. Yeah. Yeah. We have talked a lot about party planning committee scenes and how much fun we had getting to do them as actors, right? Yeah. And I just loved, loved Rashida that you got to be in on that and that you guys, like that we got to sit in there and play.
That was the most fun. So fun. Particularly there's that scene, Rashida, where you try to participate in the party. You try to throw out some ideas of things you guys used to do in Stanford and Angela just shuts you down. Yeah, they're like good ideas. A raffle. Very good. As we will see played out in a successful party in the break room. She just had it out for me. I mean, I don't actually, I don't take it personally. I think it was just like that's that was your place to shine. And that was your committee for so long. Well, it's like the people that only have a tiny bit of power, but with that power, it just means everything. Yes. Everything. Yes. I mean, so I think that was the party
planning committee was her thing. And if you mess with it, she spiraled out. There's a deleted talking head that's not in the episode, but it's on the DVDs. Oh, you're like, I don't know. We didn't have a party planning committee in Stanford. Like, it's really funny because you're just like, why is there a committee? Yeah. I mean, I love, I also love those scenes. Those are my favorite scenes on the show is like when you're all kind of stuck in a room and there's like a rhythm to the scene because A, I get church giggles, even though I'm Jewish, but I do. And also like, it's just so fun to watch the ping pong of like, you know, Phyllis's eyes dart or like, you know, like, Kate be like, yes, like, please, anything with alcohol
I'm in. Or like, just to see that I love watching the rhythm of like, especially because it was like, it's all ladies that scene, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's just so fun. It's great. Rashida, I have to bring this up. We've been tracking this. I call it wishy washy gym. And I want to get your take on wishy washy gym. I am annoyed that Jim did not tell Karen about his past with Pam at Dunder Mifflin. She walks into this whole world, this whole thing, she has no idea. Yeah. And then it's sort of, he doesn't tell Pam that he's seen Karen. So there's this whole like, many episodes where these two women, Karen is in the dark, Pam is like, sensing something, but trying to figure it out. Well, I think this speaks
to a larger thing, which is like, in the lore of the office universe, like, you know, I take Umbridge with like, what Karen means now in the modern day, because I think neither, neither Rashida Rashida is definitely not a Karen. And even Karen is from the office is not Karen, like, because she's she's up for a good time. She's not a tattletale. She's not a racist. But anyway, the point being, like, there is this thing, right? Like Karen is sort of designed to be the third point in the triangle, which is was designed to be a thing to, to like, make people feel like they wanted they wanted Pam and Jim to be like drawn closer together, driven closer together. So like, I was kind of a tool in
that way, you know, and, and so everything was like, I remember like the writers talking about it, they just didn't want to push anything too far in each direction. But yes, I think that the that the end, end result is that Jim ends up being like, not great to me and not great to you because he's like, not really being honest with anybody. But I guess you could chalk it up to his confusion about what he wants. Yeah, but I agree with you. It's irritating. And I think in real life, that would be like super annoying. You know, yeah, well, I think what I found in the rewatch is that I am siding more with your character. I'm having sympathy for her. Like, of course, I want Jim and Pam to end up together. But
at the same time, it's it's making me like the tension. I just like this poor woman. Yeah, she just loves him. She's just she knows nothing. She knows nothing. She knows nothing. So it's making me very much side with your character, I have to say. And I'm Pam. There's like this meme that's like, like for kids who grew up watching the office, it's like, like that feeling when you realize that the only reason you hated Karen was because you wanted Pam and Jim to be together and you realized that she did nothing wrong. But that's like a thing. Yeah, that's like a thing that kids are like, which is kind of cool. It's like providing this opportunity to like see people in a more nuanced way for kids who grew
up being like, that's the enemy and that's the people that want to be together. Now they're like, wait a second, she's like, not that bad. It's just that I wanted her not to be with him. I wanted her to be with him, you know, they're growing, they're learning. Well, before you leave, do you have any other memories or behind the scenes stories that you want to share? It doesn't even have to be about this episode. It could be about just your time on the show. You know, it's funny watching it, I was like, it made me really nostalgic because it just reminded me of all the like little moments and like, I don't, you know, like I haven't
talked about it in so long, but I just remember like, Ed and I, there's a line where Andy says in this episode, oh no, sorry, it's the next episode where he goes, there's only two left and I'm going to be the last man standing. And he was the last man standing. But like, you know, Ed and I were like, it was so weird because we like started in this like weird like bizarro world version of the office for like, none of you guys were there except for John. And then we like moved over to like actually work with you guys. And then like, we didn't know how long we were going to be there. And I was like signed up for, we were set up for
four episodes. And then it was like 10. And then they were like the whole year, but it was this weird thing that was like, what is going on? Because we were like on this little train together where we were both like, just like, what's going on? This is like a crazy huge opportunity for both of us. And we would just have these little like powwows at the at our trailer or tiny little trailers and just like, try to check in and see what was going on because it really was like, it's such a game changer for me. And like, and everybody was so nice to me. And it just just everybody was everybody's so different on the show. So like, I think just to like get to know you all and Phyllis like the ladies
were like my favorite, like just so it was such a like formative time for me in my life, you know? Yeah, really was. Well, Rashida, we loved you too. And I know we should probably wrap up your interview because we could talk to you forever. But I want to give a little shout out to hashtag black AF. It was so fun to get to work with you again. You're so hilarious in this. You play Joya. Yeah, that's such a fun character. So fun. She's so complicated. She's so layered like she's like a good mom. She's a crappy mom. She's all over the place like in her marriage. I know it's done in the mockumentary style to like the premises that your daughter is doing this documentary of your family, her dad, who's this writer
and creator of a TV show. And it's for it's like in place of her college essay, right? Is that the idea? Yeah. Yeah. And so you guys do talking heads, but she's also like capturing video and then more formally. Sometimes you guys are performing for the camera a little bit. A little bit. As you know, it's there. Rashida, you're such an amazing writer, director, performer, actress. Is there anything else we can share? I mean, oh, I have, I produced a show that's on Quibi that I love and I think everybody should go watch if they have Quibi or if they don't, then they can, I don't know, get a trial or something. My friend Maurice Harris, he's this beautiful florist, artist, dancer. It's just like a magical person. And
we produced this show called Centerpiece, which is where he sits with an artist and they talk about their process and their life and their childhood. And then he creates this beautiful like magical centerpiece. It's like the embodiment of their life and art and journey. And it's just like a cool, like wonderful little inspiring show. I want to see it. I want to centerpiece. Yeah. Centerpiece. Okay, guys. Well, Rashida, thank you so, so much. Thank you. So fun. I'll come back. Come back. I mean, you didn't invite me, but if you invite me, I will come back. Okay, okay. You are officially invited and you will officially come back. I can't wait. Great. Rashida, I hope we get to go on a boat again. I know. We'll podcast. I do
love a boat. So I can, I can be the recurring character on your boat cast. Boat cast? Roadmark. Roadmark. Boat casting with Jenna and Angela, with special guest, Rashida Jones. Oh my God, I love it. All right, guys, we're back because it's a Christmas miracle. Dwight has run over a goose. It's a Christmas miracle. That's what he says. And then he flops it on your desk. Yeah. He flops a dead goose on Pam's desk. And then my favorite is when Toby comes in and he's like Dwight, we've talked about this. He said we talked about it for like half an hour. Yeah, you have to stop bringing dead animals into the office. Well, we had
a lot of fan questions about this cold open Angela. Okay, let's hear it. This one always delights me. Logan Yencer, Kayla Sewell, Carrie Rice, Dmitri Lizzu and Harshita Verma all asked if Phil Shea made the goose that Dwight carries in. He did. Yeah. He had to make and find that goose. That's another day in the life of Phil Shea. What are you doing today, Phil? Yeah. I'm making a dead goose. Actually, I'm making five different types of dead goose. And then I'm going to take photos of them. And then, you know, the executive producers and writers are going to pick which dead goose. But I have eight dead goose. You know what I mean? Exactly. That's more of what Phil Shea did that week. Yeah. He's going
to have like a portfolio of dead geese. Jenna, so many people have huddled around Pam's desk about this. Phyllis, Kevin, Creed, Jim, Toby, they're all discussing this. Everyone has grossed out. But Phyllis. Yeah. Phyllis is kind of like, that seems reasonable. She's got no problem with it. What's that about? What is that about? I mean, I feel like this is the first time ever, quote me if I'm wrong out there, internet folks. This is the first time that Creed says something is crazy. Creed is like, that's crazy. Well, we've got a fan catch, Angela. Nia Shaw, Christian Harper, Kimberly Klassen and Rebecca McAllister all noticed that while Creed is in this cold open, giving his two cents about the goose, in the
next scene, he enters for the day and takes a toy. Yes. At four minutes, 10 seconds, all of a sudden, Creed is arriving for the first time. He's in his coat, the whole thing. And I was like, wait, that's continuity error. So we probably shot that cold open a different day, right? Well, guess what, Ange? I went back to the old script Aruni. Oh. And this entire cold open about the goose is not even in there. They added it. They added it. They added it. The original beginning of this scene was Michael riding in on his bike. So we shot this cold open and added it later. And somebody obviously just forgot that Creed shouldn't be at work yet. Yeah. Well, I have a little bit of a Creed catch that I'm going to call
spiky Creed hair. Oh, okay. Got some classic spiky Creed hair in this one. All right. I mean, literally, it's like this, like I want to take a screen grab of it and text it to Creed and be like, what was this phase of your hair? It's very floofy. I would describe it more like floofy than spiky. Okay. floofy Creed hair. Track it. Okay. I have taken us on a hair tangent, but let's get back to the episode. Do you remember Steve trying to ride that bike in? I about fell off my couch laughing from the memory of shooting that scene of Steve riding the bicycle into the office. When he curses, that was Steve and they bleeped it out and it was so funny and you can almost start to see him break. But that was like,
I feel like that was take like 72 or something and he was like, you guys, you have to understand there was not a lot of space there and it was like, it was like, like an S. Do you know what I mean? So you, you had to come out of that elevator and then about five steps, there's like a hard right, then there's like a left, then a right and he had to get on a bike and balance and then try to maneuver this really quick zigzag into the office in one take. And it was not easy. So then Michael does something in this episode that I just love so much because I love a Christmas pun. I really enjoy them. I also really enjoy any pun and like the hair salon genre, if you will, the hair salon puns are the best like
我觉得那是大约第 72 次拍摄之类的，他说，你们大家，你们必须明白，那里没有多少空间，而且它就像，它就像，就像一个 S 形。你知道我的意思吗？所以你，你必须从那个电梯里出来，然后大约走五步，有一个急右转，然后有一个左转，再右转，他必须骑上自行车保持平衡，然后试图在一组镜头内，非常快地以之字形穿梭进办公室。这可不容易。所以接下来迈克尔在这集中做了一件事，我非常非常喜欢，因为我喜欢关于圣诞节的双关语。我真的很喜欢它们。我也非常喜欢任何双关语，比如美发沙龙类型的，如果你愿意的话，美发沙龙的双关语是最棒的，像
hair today gone tomorrow. I love all those. Now let me ask you this question. Okay. Is that hair like hair on your head? Like a rabbit hair today gone tomorrow and then it's like a rabbit hopping away. Why would, why would, if you were a hair salon, why would you have a rabbit and not use the word hair? If you were a hair salon, why would you use the pun hair today gone tomorrow because they cut it off? Yes. Oh, lady. Okay. Anyway, so he hits Pam with a whole bunch of Christmas puns. I can't believe you're just getting that what's happening. So he just is about to lay him out one after another. He's like, I was like a nice slice of Christmas Pam with the side of candy pams or perhaps some pamp
今朝美发，明日无踪。我喜欢所有这些。现在让我问你这个问题。好吧。那个“发”是指头上的头发吗？就像兔子一样，今朝美发，明日无踪，然后它就像一只兔子跳走了。为什么，为什么，如果你是一家美发沙龙，你为什么要养一只兔子却不用“发”这个词呢？如果你是一家美发沙龙，你为什么要用“今朝美发，明日无踪”这个双关语？因为他们把它剪掉了。是的。噢，天哪。好吧。不管怎样，他用一连串的圣诞双关语向帕姆发起猛攻。我简直不敢相信你才反应过来发生了什么。所以他接下来是一个接一个地朝她抛出这些。他说，我就像是一片美好的圣诞帕姆蛋糕，配上一份糖果帕姆，或者也许是一些帕姆
chops. He's just like boom, boom, boom. He really does. While Michael has a talking head where he says it's going to be the best Christmas ever because his girlfriend Carol is coming to the Christmas party and he has a surprise for her two tickets to Sandals resort Jamaica. It's all inclusive. He's just so proud that this resort is all inclusive. It's his selling point as he tries to get many women to go on this trip with him. So guys now Carol enters and she's looking for Michael. She goes in his office and she confronts him. She's upset that he photoshopped a picture of himself onto her old family ski trip photo with her ex-husband and he sent it out to people with the message skisans greetings. He says a Christmas
排。他简直就像是“砰，砰，砰”。他真的这么做了。与此同时，迈克尔有一个单人访谈镜头，他说这将是有史以来最好的圣诞节，因为他的女朋友卡罗尔要来参加圣诞派对，他给她准备了一个惊喜——牙买加桑德斯度假村的双人机票。这是一价全包的。他为这个度假村是一价全包的而感到无比自豪。这是他的卖点，他试图让许多女性和他一起去这次旅行。好了，伙计们，现在卡罗尔进来了，她在找迈克尔。她走进他的办公室，质问他。她很不高兴，因为他把自己的照片 P 到她以前和前夫一起去家庭滑雪旅行的照片上，然后把照片发给大家，并附上了“滑雪季节日快乐”的信息。他说，这是一个圣诞
Carol skisans greetings. Sand question from Allison Catrion, Sarah, Joe, Lisa and Elise. Were the kids in the Christmas card photo actually Stephen Nancy's since they were married in real life? No. No. They had Nancy pose for a photo with a couple of kids and a really tall guy that was going to be her ex-husband and then they photoshop Steve's face onto his face. But those are not Stephen Nancy's kids in real life. I like that it's a crappy photoshop because I believe it. It's not even well done. Well, we've seen Michael's photoshop skills from when he photoshopped us in that office group photo. Yeah. So he clearly has not learned anything from then until now. But Carol ends up breaking up with Michael.
卡罗尔，滑雪季节日快乐。桑德斯。来自艾莉森、凯特琳、萨拉、乔、莉萨和埃莉斯的提问：圣诞卡照片里的孩子真的是斯蒂芬和南希的孩子吗，既然他们在现实生活中结婚了？不是的。不是。他们让南希和几个孩子以及一个很高的、将扮演她前夫的男人一起摆好姿势拍了张照片，然后把史蒂夫的脸 P 到那个男人的脸上。但照片里的并不是斯蒂芬和南希在现实生活中的孩子。我喜欢这个劣质的 P 图，因为我相信它。它甚至没做好。好吧，我们见识过迈克尔的 P 图技术，就是他把我们 P进那张办公室集体照的时候。是的。所以很明显，从那时候到现在，他什么也没学到。但卡罗尔最终还是和迈克尔分手了。
And Michael is devastated because he's like, no, Carol, can I tempt you to stay with me so that we can go to the all inclusive Sandals Resort we leave day after tomorrow? Well, I mean, Michael, come on. She's a single mom with two kids. You can't spring a surprise trip. That's not to say you already did a grand proposal to her. Now you have photoshopped your head on her ex-husband. And now you're gonna like try to say, but we have this last minute trip that you haven't planned for this will seal the deal. I thought the same thing. I was like, she has two small children. It is the holidays. You think she doesn't have her own holiday traditions and a very complicated like custody arrangement? Probably you think
而迈克尔崩溃了，因为他说，不，卡罗尔，我能诱惑你留下来和我一起去那个一价全包的桑德斯度假村吗？我们后天就出发。好吧，我是说，迈克尔，拜托。她是一个带着两个孩子的单亲妈妈。你不能突然抛出一个惊喜旅行。更不用说你之前已经向她进行过盛大的求婚了。现在你把自己的头 P 在她前夫身上。然后你现在还想说，我们还有这个你根本没计划过的最后一分钟旅行，这就能板上钉钉了。我也是这么想的。我想：她有两个幼儿。现在是假期。你觉得她没有自己的节日传统和非常复杂的抚养权安排吗？大概吧，你觉得
she can just fly off to Sandals Jamaica with 48 hours notice? This is just another example of the disconnect here for Michael and this relationship. Yeah. By the way, once you have young children, there's no last minute anything. No. As far as like your adult life, you don't just get to go out to dinner last minute or meet people for drinks last minute or take a trip last minute that those days are over. Michael and Carol have a pretty fantastic breakup moment. If you're Carol, cause it's sort of a power play. Michael goes, you walk out that door and it's over. And Carol goes, I know. It's kind of, it's kind of like boss lady moment. Yeah, I know. I'm walking out the door, baby. Bye. Should we talk about
她能提前 48 小时说飞就飞去牙买加桑德斯度假村吗？这只是迈克尔和这段关系脱节的又一个例子。是的。顺便说一句，一旦你有了幼儿，就没有什么临时起意的事情了。没有。就你的成年生活而言，你不能只是临时起意去吃晚饭，或者临时起意和别人喝一杯，或者临时起意去旅行——那些日子已经一去不复返了。迈克尔和卡罗尔的分手时刻相当精彩。如果你是卡罗尔的话，因为这有点像是一场权力游戏。迈克尔说：“你走出那扇门，就一切都结束了。”卡罗尔说：“我知道。”这有点像，有点像是霸气女王的时刻。是的，我知道。我要走出这扇门了，宝贝。再见。我们该聊聊
another gift that doesn't go well in this episode? Pam's gift to Jim. You mean the scene that I just wrote on my note card as. Yeah. Oof. Ouch. Pam calls Jim over to her desk and she's like, Hey, I need to give you your present early. I've been sending Dwight communications from the CIA for a couple of months. And the gift is that you get to decide his final mission. Oh, she's so excited. She has a little red folder. She's handing him. She's so excited that this is just going to tickle Jim and they're going to be back together in their prank wars with Dwight. But Jim turns her down. He's like, you know what? I just, I just don't think I should be doing this anymore because of my promotion. But then he has a
本集中另一个进展不顺的礼物吗？帕姆送给吉姆的礼物。你是说我刚刚在便签纸上写下的那个场景吗？是啊。噢。哎哟。帕姆把吉姆叫到她的办公桌前，她说：“嘿，我需要早点把礼物给你。几个月来，我一直以中央情报局的名义给德怀特发送密信。”而礼物就是，你可以决定他的最终任务。哦，她太兴奋了。她手里拿着一个红色的文件夹，正递给他。她太兴奋了，觉得这一定会让吉姆觉得很有趣，他们将和德怀特重新回到恶作剧大战中。但吉姆拒绝了她。他说：“你知道吗？我只是，我只是觉得因为我升职了，我不应该再做这种事了。”但随后他有一个
talking head where he says he can't fall back into doing all the things he used to do. Otherwise, what's the point? He said it's a chance to start over. That one had to hurt when he walked away and didn't take the folder and Pam, it's just holding this folder of these ridiculous CIA letters. Your look, it's painful. Yeah. Well, now, Michael is devastated because Carol has broken up with him and he comes out and he says, Christmas is canceled. He's canceling it. And Stanley's like, you can't cancel a holiday. And Michael is like on the verge of tears. And he's like, Jim, take New Year's away from Stanley. Like, he's really about to spiral out.
单人访谈镜头，他说他不能再回到过去做那些他以前常做的事情了，否则还有什么意义？他说这是一个重新开始的机会。当他走开没有拿走文件夹时，那一定很受伤，而帕姆只是拿着这个装有这些荒谬的中央情报局信件的文件夹。你的表情，太痛苦了。是的。好吧，现在，迈克尔崩溃了，因为卡罗尔跟他分手了，他走出来说：“圣诞节取消了。”他在取消圣诞节。斯坦利说：“你不能取消一个节日。”迈克尔险些哭出来，他说：“吉姆，把新年的假期从斯坦利身上剥夺吧。”就像，他真的快要彻底失控了。
Well, lady, did you notice that eight minutes and 47 seconds, there is an amazing shot of the accountant's stack. I say the accounting stack, but with Andy. Yeah. Mm-hmm. There you guys are. You're all standing there at the edge of the desk in your accountant's stack. We're, we're standing there. And this is the first shot you get of the blouse. I absolutely hated. I hated this blouse so much because it had, and I counted 32 buttons. What? 32 buttons. And they were tiny little pearl flat buttons, like the size of like your pinky fingernail, like tiny. And I had to button 32 buttons. And literally, they would knock on my door like, Angela, they're ready for you on set. And I'm like, still buttoning.
好吧，女士，你有没有注意到，在第 8 分钟 47 秒时，有一个关于会计组座位的绝佳特写镜头？我指的是会计组，还有安迪。是的。嗯哼。你们就在那里。你们都站在办公桌边缘的会计组座位上。我们，我们站在那里。这是你那件衬衫的第一个镜头。我真的恨死那件衬衫了。我太恨这件衬衫了，因为它有——我数过了—— 32 颗纽扣。什么？32 颗纽扣。它们是那种珍珠色的小平扣，就像你的小指指甲盖那么大，非常小。我得系 32 颗纽扣。真的，他们会敲我的门说：“安吉拉，片场准备好了。”而我说：“还在系扣子。”
Well, couldn't you have just undone a few of them and pulled it over your head? No. No. Because it was so fitted in the armpits. Oh. And I had, and they buttoned all the way up to the top of my neck. It was like a turtleneck, but in full of buttons. Lady. Wow. I remember that. Now that you're saying it, I remember the week of the tiny buttons. Mm-hmm. And I remember Carrie, our wardrobe stylist, saying to me, if we ever, ever use the shirt again, I'm going to strip out these buttons and put a Velcro or something because it was driving us both crazy. But I believe you never wore that again. No. I think Carrie and I were both like, forget it. There were buttons down the arms. There
好吧，难道你不能解开几个然后把它从头上套过去吗？不行。不行。因为它的胳肢窝剪裁太修身了。哦。而且我必须，它们一直系到我的脖子顶端。这就像是一件高领衫，但上面全都是纽扣。女士。哇。我记得那个。经你这么一说，我想起那个充满小纽扣的一周了。嗯哼。我还记得我们的服装造型师凯莉对我说：“如果我们再、再穿这件衬衫，我要把这些纽扣拆掉，换成魔术贴什么的，因为它把我们两个都逼疯了。”但我相信你再也没穿过那件衬衫。没有。我想凯莉和我当时都觉得：算了吧。连袖子上都有纽扣。那里
were buttons from my neck all the way. Like, I mean, literally to my thigh. That shirt was so long, too. I think it was such a good shirt for your character, though. No, it was perfect. It was so fussy and lacy and I know it was like ye olde Christmas. And I had my nutcracker. Yes. I had my nutcracker pin on because for me, the theme was very clear of this party. Well, I think this leads us very well into the conference room for our PPC meeting on the nutcracker Christmas, which you start by insulting Phyllis. Yeah, I'm mad and I take it out on Phyllis and repeat. That is Angela Martin. I tell Phyllis to get green streamers and Phyllis gives me a little Phyllis sass and says, I thought you said
从我的脖子一直到。我是说，真的直到我的大腿。那件衬衫也太长了。不过我觉得这件衬衫对你的角色来说真的很棒。不，它太完美了。它太繁复、太多蕾丝了，我知道这就像是老式的圣诞节。我戴着胡桃夹子胸针。是的。我戴着我的胡桃夹子胸针，因为对我来说，这个派对的主题非常明确。嗯哼。好吧，我觉得这非常自然地把我们带到了会议室，来开我们的派对策划委员会会议，讨论胡桃夹子主题的圣诞节，而你一开头就侮辱了菲莉丝。是的，我很生气，我把气撒在菲莉丝身上，再说一遍。这就是安吉拉·马丁。我告诉菲莉丝去买绿色饰带，而菲莉丝对我进行了一点菲莉丝式的回嘴，说：“我以为你说过
green was hoarse. And I mean, Angela is not having it. She's like, no, orange is hoarse, which is the color that Phyllis was wearing. Well, Karen now decides to propose a few traditions that were typical at Stanford. We've got the raffle. We've got the karaoke. And Angela just shuts down everything and then throws Karen out of the meeting. Well, she suggests a Christmas drinking game and I'm like, God help you. That's it. And I escort her to the door. Angela is just so ticked off. She starts off ticked off. She finishes ticked off. But I love Jenna that she just keeps going back to and none of them are on the theme of a nutcracker Christmas. A nutcracker Christmas. I don't know if you've ever tried to coordinate
绿色是粗俗的。”我是说，安吉拉可不吃这一套。她说：“不，橙色才是粗俗的，”那是菲莉丝当时穿的衣服的颜色。好吧，凯伦现在决定提出一些在斯坦福很典型的传统。我们有抽奖活动。我们有卡拉OK。而安吉拉直接否决了一切，然后把凯伦赶出了会议。好吧，她建议玩一个圣诞饮酒游戏，而我心想：上帝保佑你。就是这样。我把她护送到了门外。安吉拉真是气炸了。她一开始就很生气。她结束时也很生气。但我喜欢詹娜的一点是，她一直在重提这些，而其中没有一个符合胡桃夹子圣诞节的主题。胡桃夹子圣诞节。我不知道你有没有尝试过去协调过
a party with someone who's very, very big on theme. Have you in your real life? I'm not you, Jenna. Well, that's what I was going to say. I feel like maybe you've done that when we've planned a party. I think there are two type of people who play on parties. There's people who are just like, we'll just throw it together, which is kind of me. I'm just like, yeah, yeah, whatever. Let's just I'll grab whatever snacks we have and we'll just invite people. But then there's the people that are like, I need a theme and we're all going to stick to the theme. And here's the theme. And if you waver from the theme, I will be passed off. And
一个对主题非常、非常执着的人一起办派对。你在现实生活中经历过吗？我可不是你，詹娜。好吧，这正是我要说的。我觉得也许当我们策划派对时你这么干过。我觉得办派对的人分两种。有一种人就是：“我们随便凑合一下就行了，”这有点像我。我基本上就是：“行啊，行啊，随便。我就抓一把我们有什么零食，然后邀请大家来。”但还有一种人是：“我需要一个主题，我们所有人都必须遵守这个主题。这就是主题。如果你偏离了这个主题，我就会大发雷霆。”然后
Well, the funny thing, Angela, is I think you would throw the Margarita karaoke party. You would throw the party with just all the random most fun stuff. Yes. And you would throw the nutcracker themed party and there'd be nutcrackers everywhere. Yeah. Nutcracker cookies, nutcracker cake. There would be, I don't know, maybe a handout on the history of the nutcracker, perhaps. I don't know. We'd have the nutcracker playing on television. The ballet. Yes.
好吧，有趣的是，安吉拉，我觉得你会办玛格丽塔卡拉OK派对。你会举办那种只有各种随机最有趣东西的派对。是的。而你也会举办胡桃夹子主题的派对，到处都是胡桃夹子。是的。胡桃夹子饼干，胡桃夹子蛋糕。还会，我不知道，也许会有一份关于胡桃夹子历史的宣传册之类的。我不知道。我们会在电视上播放胡桃夹子。芭蕾舞剧。是的。
You know what I'm saying? Yes. Well, now we go into Michael's office and he is wallowing. He's listening to a clip of Goodbye My Lover. He hasn't purchased it, though. Just a clip. He's just listening to the free part on repeat. Goodbye, my love. Goodbye, my friend. And Dwight enters and he's like, we're getting rid of everything that reminds you of Carol.
你知道我在说什么吗？是的。好吧，现在我们走进迈克尔的办公室，他在顾影自怜。他在听一首《再见，我的爱人》的片段。不过他还没买。只是一个片段。他只是在单曲循环免费的那部分。再见，我的爱。再见，我的朋友。然后德怀特进来了，他说：“我们要把所有让你想起卡罗尔的东西都扔掉。”
We're getting rid of all of it. Dwight is that classic Dwight thing, though, of while someone else is maybe hurting or trying to forget about something. He thinks he's helping, but he's just like, wow, Carol was a really good realtor. Oh, look what she did with this mold. She's like going through her condo, like contract and praising her. She's smart. Yeah. Well, Pam is over at reception and she sees Karen now. She has a talking head where she says, I've been a little cold to Karen for no reason. She's never done anything to me. And then we see Pam walk over to Karen's desk and kind of apologize and say, hey, I'm
我们要把所有这些都扔掉。不过德怀特就是有那种典型的德怀特作风，当别人可能在伤心或者试图忘记某事时。他觉得自己是在帮忙，但他只是在说：“哇，卡罗尔真是个不错的房地产经纪人。哦，看看她是怎么处理这处霉菌的。”他就像是在翻阅她的公寓合同并赞美她。她很聪明。是的。好吧，帕姆在接待处那边，她现在看到了凯伦。她有一个单人访谈镜头，她说：“我之前对凯伦有点冷淡，而且毫无理由。她从来没对我做过什么。”然后我们看到帕姆走到凯伦的桌子旁，主动道歉并说：“嘿，我
really sorry that meeting was like that, that Angela was mean. And now I guess Pam and Karen are going to bond. And if you look at the shot of Jim's face, it's so good. He's like, what is happening? Yeah. Well, listen, I mean, I feel like Jim set a clear boundary at the beginning of the episode. He's like, hey, listen, things are different now. I'm not going to get into it with you. And I think this is a little bit of Pam taking him at his word and being like, okay, well, you know what? I'm going to step up and I'm going to treat this person the way I would treat them if I didn't have a past with Jim.
真的很抱歉刚才那场会议会那样，安吉拉太刻薄了。”现在我想帕姆和凯伦要建立感情了。如果你看看吉姆脸上的表情，太棒了。他心想：这到底是怎么回事？是的。好吧，听着，我的意思是我觉得吉姆在这一集开始时划定了一条清晰的界限。他说：“嘿，听着，现在情况不同了。我不会跟你掺和这些的。”我觉得这有点像是帕姆把他的话当真了，然后心想：“好吧，你知道吗？我要振作起来，我要用我没有和吉姆有过过去的那种态度来对待这个人。”
Right. If this woman came into the office, this is how I would behave. And that's how I'm going to behave. Yeah. I think Pam is trying to be a grown up too. Well, now the war has begun. I mean, Angela, of course, is, you know, being crappy to Phyllis, they're hanging up their sign. And she was like, this should have been hung two days ago. And then who just comes in and hangs up their sign over my sign? Yeah. Our party also starts 15 minutes before yours. And our poster is more brightly colored, shady. And Kelly says, this looks fun. And then Kevin walks over and Angela's getting ticked off. So she rips your sign down.
对。如果这个女人来到办公室，我就是这么表现的。那我接下来也要这么表现。是的。我觉得帕姆也在努力做一个成年人。好吧，现在战争已经开始了。我是说，安吉拉当然（你知道的）对菲莉丝很刻薄，她们在挂标语。安吉拉说：“这个本应该在两天前就挂上去的。”然后谁刚进来，把他们的标语挂在了我的标语上面？是的。我们的派对也比你们的早 15 分钟开始。而且我们的海报颜色更鲜艳，太讽刺了。凯利说：“这看起来挺有意思的。”然后凯文走了过来，安吉拉快气炸了。于是她把你们的海报扯了下来。
I know. And then Karen rips down a nutcracker Christmas sign. I know it is on. And there is a deleted scene. So right after I ripped that poster down, my character goes over to Toby and is like, you have got to cancel their party. We can't have two parties. This isn't like sanctioned. They don't have a budget and on and on and on. And she's just reading him the riot act. And Toby says they can throw their party. It's a free country. And my character slaps him across the face. What? Yes. Yes. And then Toby's like, oh, that really hurt. And then I say, I'm trying to wake you up. Wake up. There can only be one party. And then Toby's like, that really hurt. And you can't touch
我知道。然后凯伦也扯下了一张胡桃夹子圣诞节的标语。我知道，这下彻底开战了。还有一个被删减的片段。就在我把那张海报扯下来之后，我的角色走到托比面前说：“你必须取消他们的派对。我们不能有两个派对。这不是官方批准的。他们没有预算，诸如此类，诸如此类。”她简直是在向他严厉训斥。而托比说他们可以办他们的派对。这是一个自由的国家。然后我的角色一巴掌扇在他脸上。什么？是的。是的。然后托比说：“哦，这真的很疼。”接着我说：“我这是在试图唤醒你。醒醒。只能有一个派对。”然后托比说：“这真的很疼。你不能动手
people. You can't hit people. And I'm going to write you up. Wow. And then I say to Toby, you know what? Michael was right. You are pathetic. Wow. I know. Well, so, you know, Angela, what you didn't see in deleted scenes is that she goes to Toby for help and he's no help. So now back in the real scenes, she goes to Dwight, but there would have been a progression. She was mad. She went to Toby. He didn't help her. Now she goes to Dwight. Yes. As number three, how can he help her? He walks over to reception where Pam and Karen are on Pam's computer and he says, I am dismantling your party. I'm dismantling your committee and I'm canceling your party as ranking number three. But then Jim walks up as ranking number
打人。你不能打人。我要写报告记你过。”哇。然后我对托比说：“你知道吗？迈克尔是对的。你真可悲。”哇。我知道。好吧，所以，你知道吗，安吉拉，你在被删减片段里没看到的是，她去找托比寻求帮助，而他一点忙也帮不上。所以现在回到正片中，她去找了德怀特，但这中间本来是有一个发展过程的。她很生气。她去找了托比。他没帮她。现在她去找德怀特。是的。作为办公室三号人物，他能怎么帮她？他走到接待处，当时帕姆和凯伦正在帕姆的电脑前，他说：“我要解散你们的派对。我是以三号人物的身份来解散你们的委员会，并取消你们的派对。”但随后吉姆作为二号人物走了过来
two and he assembles a one man committee to determine the validity of the party planning committees. Wait, I have to tell you, this is the actual name of his committee. Ready? I love how many committees there are. So there's the party planning committee. There's a committee to plan parties. Now Jim is the sole member of the committee to determine the validity of the two committees. I love that. I love that. And Jenna, what does he decide? He decides in favor of Karen and Pam. He says their committee to plan parties can stand. Dwight asks if he could please become a member of the committee to determine the validity of the two committees. And Jim says permission denied. There you go. So now Michael is still
并且他成立了一个人的委员会来决定这两个派对策划委员会的合法性。等等，我必须告诉你，这是他的委员会的真实名称。准备好了吗？我喜欢这里有这么多的委员会。所以有派对策划委员会。还有一个策划派对的委员会。现在吉姆是决定两个委员会合法性委员会的唯一成员。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢了。詹娜，他作出了什么决定？他裁定凯伦和帕姆胜诉。他说他们那个策划派对的委员会可以保留。德怀特问他是否可以加入决定两个委员会合法性的委员会。而吉姆说：“不准许。”就是这样。所以现在迈克尔仍然
moping in his office and Andy invites him to lunch at Benihana to cheer him up. And then Michael invites Jim, Ryan and Dwight. But Ryan has the delicious list of excuses as to why he cannot go. He rattles them all off in a row. He says, I'm not feeling well. I've got a ton of work to do. MSG allergy, peanut allergy. I just ate there last night. And Jim is like, wow, thanks for taking all of the excuses. And then Ryan goes, doctor appointment, car trouble, planner warts, granddad fought in World War II. He's got like a ton of them. He keeps them on his phone. He's like, I keep them on my phone. You have to like stay sharp, Jim. Yeah, step it up, Jim. Welcome back. We had a fan catch from Casey
在办公室里闷闷不乐，安迪邀请他去贝尼哈纳（Benihana）吃午饭来让他高兴起来。然后迈克尔邀请了吉姆、瑞恩和德怀特。但瑞恩有一长串美味的借口，解释他为什么不能去。他连珠炮似地把它们全背了出来。他说：“我感觉不太舒服。我有一大堆工作要做。味精过敏。花生过敏。我昨晚刚在那儿吃过。”吉姆心想：“哇，谢谢你把所有的借口都用光了。”然后瑞恩又说：“看医生，车坏了，长了扁平疣，爷爷在二战中打过仗。”他大概有一大堆借口。他把它们记在手机里。他说：“我都记在手机里。你得保持敏锐，吉姆。”是的，加把劲，吉姆。欢迎回来。我们收到了来自凯西
Hilton who wants us to know that there is no Benihana in Scranton or even near Scranton. I looked that up. They have one in Pittsburgh, which is a four and a half hour drive and one in Plymouth meeting, which is a one hour and 45 minute drive. We didn't even try. We just, we're like, okay, clearly there's not one there. We're just, we're just going to write it in anyway. So they're getting their table at Benihana. And you guys know how it is. You all sit around like the stove top, right? Yeah. And, and so Michael and Andy sit together and Jim, and then there's a seat next to Jim, but a couple scooches in there before Dwight can get in there. Cause Dwight and Andy were like wrestling for the seat
希尔顿的粉丝捉虫，她想让我们知道，斯克兰顿或者斯克兰顿附近根本没有贝尼哈纳餐厅。我查过了。匹兹堡有一家，开车要四个半小时；普利茅斯米丁有一家，开车要一个小时四十五分钟。我们甚至都没试着去找。我们当时就是想，好吧，很显然那里没有一家，我们无论如何都要把它写进去。所以他们去贝尼哈纳找他们的桌子。你们也知道那是怎样的。你们都围着铁板烧炉灶坐着，对吧？是的。所以迈克尔和安迪坐在一起，还有吉姆，然后吉姆旁边有一个座位，但在德怀特坐过去之前，一对情侣抢先挤进去了。因为德怀特和安迪刚才为了抢
next to Michael. And now there's a couple there. And you guys that have watched the podcast before, you will know Stephen Sox, our stand in is the man in the couple. He got to be in the scene. And I just love that. Well, you know, on IMDB, he is credited as playing the role of Justin Spitzer. The name that they gave to the character sitting at the table is our writer's name, Justin Spitzer, played by our stand in Stephen Sox. I love that. Here's the thing. Now Dwight's on the other end of the table and he's going to have to shout throughout the rest of the time they're at Benihana. He has to keep shouting. And he's really annoying this couple in between. And Jenna, I was just like, I know it's for comedy's
迈克尔旁边的座位还在那儿争抢。现在那里坐了一对情侣。看过这个播客的听众朋友们，你们会知道我们的替身演员斯蒂芬·索克斯就是那对情侣里的男士。他得以在这个场景里出镜。我真是太喜欢这个了。好吧，你知道的，在 IMDb 上，他被署名扮演贾斯汀·斯普策这个角色。给坐在桌子旁的这个角色起的名字就是我们编剧的名字，贾斯汀·斯普策，由我们的替身演员斯蒂芬·索克斯扮演。我太喜欢这个了。事情是这样的。现在德怀特坐在桌子的另一头，他必须在他们呆在贝尼哈纳的剩余时间里大喊大叫。他必须不停地大喊。他真的惹恼了中间的那对情侣。詹娜，我当时就想，我知道这是为了喜剧
sake, but you know, that couple would have been like, do you want to trade seats so you're next to your friend? I thought the same thing. I thought the same thing. What? They want this guy shouting over them through the whole meal? No. Of course not. But you know what? Maybe they had already started to get their food or something and it just felt like a huge headache. I don't know. But they, they stay. They're like, no, we want to be in the center of the table. We want to see the chef most clearly. I don't know what their motivation was for not letting this guy sit with his group. But so Michael is still being mopey, even though they're at Benihana, you know, he wants to call Carol and Andy's like, uh-uh,
效果，但你知道，那对情侣本可以问：“你想换个座位，这样你就能挨着你的朋友了吗？”我也是这么想的。我也是这么想的。什么？他们希望这家伙在整顿饭期间都在他们头上大喊大叫吗？不。当然不。但你知道吗？也许他们已经开始吃他们的食物什么的了，而这感觉像是一个巨大的麻烦。我不知道。但他们留下来了。他们心想：“不，我们要坐在桌子中央。我们想最清楚地看到厨师。”我不知道他们为什么不让这家伙和他的朋友坐在一起。但无论如何，迈克尔依然闷闷不乐，尽管他们都在贝尼哈纳了，你知道的，他想给卡罗尔打电话，而安迪说：“呃-uh，”
let's start ordering drinks. He starts ordering this weird eggnog sake concoction. It sounds disgusting. We had a fan question from Dan Solomon who wanted to know, was that a real drink or was it invented by the writers? It's a made up drink. This is not a real drink. Angela, someone on cracked.com did an article where they made all kinds of fake cocktails from different TV shows. Like they made cocktails from 30 Rock and Parks and Rec and they did a review of this drink. Just to remind you, it is one part eggnog and three part sake. It sounds so gross. All right. Here's what they had to say. Quote, it looks like so many different disgusting things and none of them are anything I would want to put in my mouth.
我们开始点饮料。他开始点那种奇怪的蛋酒清酒混合饮料。听起来真恶心。我们收到了丹·索罗门（Dan Solomon）的一个粉丝提问，他想知道，那真的是一种饮料，还是编剧们虚构出来的？这是一个虚构的饮料。这不是一种真正的饮料。安吉拉，cracked.com 网站上有人写过一篇文章，他们在文章中制作了各种来自不同电视剧的假鸡尾酒。比如他们制作了《我为喜剧狂》和《公园与游憩》里的鸡尾酒，他们还对这种饮料做了测评。提醒大家一下，它是一份蛋酒兑三份清酒。听起来太恶心了。好了。以下是他们的评价。原话是，它看起来像各种令人作呕的东西，没有一样是我愿意放进嘴里的。
You can actually hear the eggnog curdling in the glass. Gross. Then they said, it's not the worst thing I've ever had, but it is far from the best. The real problem lies in the aftertaste. Both of these drinks have a tendency to linger on the breath by themselves and neither is very pleasant. When mixed together, they make your mouth taste like toes. I wish I could say something nice about this drink, but every time I attempt it, I suddenly forget all the good in my life. Oh my God. Well, what I want to know now is what were those guys actually drinking on the set? Were they drinking water mixed with eggnog? Were they just drinking eggnog? I don't know. I don't like eggnog, so I'm not a big eggnog person.
你甚至能听到蛋酒在杯子里凝固的声音。真恶心。然后他们说，这倒不是我喝过最糟糕的东西，但它远算不上最好。真正的问题在于余味。这两种饮料本身都有在呼吸中久久不散的倾向，而且哪一种都不太好闻。混合在一起后，它们会让你的嘴里尝起来像脚趾头。我真希望我对这款饮料能说点好话，但每次我一尝试，我就会突然忘记我生活中的所有美好。噢，天哪。好吧，我现在想知道的是，那些人在片场实际上在喝什么？他们喝的是加了蛋酒的水吗？他们只是在喝蛋酒吗？我不知道。我不喜欢蛋酒，所以我不是那种特别喜欢蛋酒的人。
I liked it as a kid, but as an adult, it's just, it's very thick. It's like drinking a dessert. It's so sweet. Yeah. We should go back because I need to talk to you a little bit about this scene with Roy. So Roy comes in. He's looking cute. He clearly just wants to talk to Pam. He's asking her about her gift wrapping techniques, and she says she only uses three pieces of tape. Are you crazy? Yeah. Well, Angela, Adrienne Thornblum, Sydney Layton, and Elisa Schroeder, and Kelly Lubbert wrote in to say, how on earth can you wrap a gift with only three pieces of tape? How? Yeah. They are all saying there must be at least four. Why is Pam giving such bad advice here? Guys, it can be done. You can wrap a
我小时候挺喜欢的，但作为一个成年人，它就是，它太浓稠了。就像在喝甜点。太甜了。对。我们得回正题了，因为我需要跟你多聊聊罗伊的这场戏。所以罗伊进来了。他看起来很可爱。他显然只是想和帕姆说话。他问她关于礼品包装技巧的事，她说她只用了三块胶带。你疯了吗？是啊。好吧，安吉拉，阿德里安娜·索恩布拉姆（Adrienne Thornblum）、悉尼·莱顿（Sydney Layton）、伊莉萨·施罗德（Elisa Schroeder）和凯莉·卢伯特（Kelly Lubbert）写信来说，你怎么可能只用三块胶带就包好一份礼物？怎么可能？对。他们都在说至少得有四块。为什么帕姆在这里要给出这么糟糕的建议？伙计们，这是做得到的。你可以包一个
gift with three pieces of tape. I personally, Jenna Fisher can't do it. I use more than three pieces of tape when I wrap a gift, but because Pam says this in this episode, every Christmas, when I, Jenna Fisher, give a gift and I use more than three pieces of tape, people comment on it. Oh, no. Do they really? Yes. Yes. They're like, use more than three pieces of tape, eh? And I'm like, I am not Pam. I can't wrap. Apparently, Pam can. You can watch a ton of YouTube videos on how exactly Pam does it. Many people have made videos on how to wrap a gift with only three pieces of tape, so it can be done, but... Hold up, lady. Yeah. People commenting on your tape, that's got to be in your family because
只用了三块胶带的礼物。我个人，詹娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）是做不到的。我包礼物用的胶带可不止三块，但因为帕姆在这集里这么说了，所以每年圣诞节，当我——詹娜·费舍尔——送礼物并且用了不止三块胶带时，大家都会对此评头论足。哦，不。真的吗？是的。是的。他们会说，用了不止三块胶带吧，嗯？而我会说，我不是帕姆。我不会包。显然，帕姆会。你可以在 YouTube 上看一大堆关于帕姆究竟是怎么做到的视频。很多人都制作了关于如何只用三块胶带包装礼物的视频，所以这是可以做到的，但是……等等，女士。是的。大家对你的胶带评头论足，那一定是在你们家，因为
who you're giving? At Christmas, you're like, with your family. Yeah. So you've got like some aunt that's like, oh, you use more than three pieces. Yeah. Yeah. I get grief. I get grief from my family and some friends for not being your character. Yeah. I mean, that's the tricky thing about having a character that you played for a long time who makes grand declarations. It gets super imposed on to me. But you know, do you know what I get almost every single year from a family member? I get at least one gift that has a cat on it. Yeah. I like cats, Jenna. Angela Martin likes cats. Yeah. I like cats. I don't need a gift every year with a cat on it, guys, from my own family. Yeah. My favorite is more
你把礼物送给谁？在圣诞节，你就像是在跟你的家人一起。对。所以你会有某个姑妈之类的亲戚说，哦，你用了不止三块胶带啊。对。对。我因为没能成为你的角色而受到我家人和一些朋友的抱怨。对。我的意思是，扮演一个持续了很长时间、会发表宏伟宣言的角色，最棘手的事情就在于此。这会被强加到我身上。但你知道吗，我几乎每年都会从家庭成员那里收到什么吗？我至少会收到一件上面印着猫的礼物。对。我喜欢猫，詹娜。安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）喜欢猫。对。我喜欢猫。伙计们，我不需要每年都从我自己的家里收到印有猫的礼物。对。我最喜欢的
than once. More than once, I have gotten a cat calendar and there's usually a photo of a cat hanging for dear life from a tree and it says, hang in there. Yeah. I've gotten that calendar more than once. Oh, no. Okay. Wait, wait, wait. We have to get back to the scene because they're flirting and then Karen sees the flirt, sees Roy and is like, he's cute. You should date him. And then Pam does not say a word. She doesn't own up and she just says, maybe. Well, I feel like Pam can't tell Karen that she used to be with Roy without it opening up a lot of questions that might lead her to having to tell her things that she knows Jim hasn't told her. I agree. Well, lady, I think we should pause
不止一次。不止一次，我收到过猫咪日历，上面通常有一张猫拼死挂在树上的照片，上面写着，坚持住。对。我收到那个日历不止一次了。哦，不。好吧。等等，等等，等等。我们得回到那个场景，因为他们在调情，然后卡伦（Karen）看到了这种调情，看到了罗伊，就觉得，他很帅。你应该和他约会。接着帕姆一言不发。她没有大方承认，只是说，也许吧。嗯，我觉得帕姆没法告诉卡伦她以前和罗伊在一起过，因为这会引发一连串的问题，可能导致她不得不说出一些她知道吉姆（Jim）还没告诉过对方的事。我同意。好吧，女士，我觉得我们应该暂停
our breakdown for this episode for a moment because this is kind of the halfway mark and we thought that this would be a good place to play our interview with Jen Salada. Yeah. I think it would be great to hear from the writer of this episode before we dig any deeper. All right, Sam, will you play the interview with Jen? Hi, Jen Salada. Hi, Jen. Guys, look gorgeous. You look literally, literally looks like time stops since I last saw you. I love you. You stop it. I'm so excited. My favorite guests are when we have writers on because you guys have this perspective that is totally different from the actors. And I could just listen to you guys talk forever. That's my it's my favorite side of the story.
我们对这集的剧情解析一会儿，因为这差不多是中间节点，我们觉得这是播放我们对简·萨拉达（Jen Salada）采访的好地方。对。在深入探讨之前，听听本集编剧的看法应该会很棒。好的，萨姆，你能播放对简的采访吗？嗨，简·萨拉达。嗨，简。伙计们，看起来太美了。你们看起来简直，简直就像时间自从我上次见到你们以来就静止了一样。我爱你们。少来这套。我太兴奋了。我最喜欢的嘉宾是编剧们，因为你们有一种与演员完全不同的视角。我可以听你们说上一整天。这是我最，我最喜欢的故事视角。
That is probably Phil Shea having to make all the weird props. I remember about Phil Shea is constantly when if I had to come in on like a Saturday or a Sunday because I needed to do a little work or I forgot something at the office. He was always there. He was always there making a prop. Like he just never stopped working. He was just to get brilliant. Yeah, my memory of him is him running. He was always like like across the break and he had things in his hand and I'd be like, hey, I'll be like, hey, I just got to attach this hat to the squirrel. And then I'm like, what? What made me laugh when you told me that I forgot that he presented everything on a tray and the bird thing made me laugh
那可能菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）不得不制作所有那些奇怪的道具。我对菲尔·谢伊的记忆是，如果我不得不在周六或周日来上班，因为我需要做点工作或者把什么东西忘在了办公室，他总是会在那儿。他总是坐在那儿制作道具。就像他永远不会停止工作一样。他简直太才华横溢了。对，我对他的记忆是他一直在跑。他总是像这样跑过休息室，手里拿着东西，然后我会说，嘿，我会说，嘿，我得把这顶帽子固定到松鼠身上。然后我就想，什么？当你告诉我你忘了他在托盘上呈递所有东西时，什么让我笑得那么厉害
so hard because I'm sure that is I can imagine that I can picture that. And I wanted to tell you the when I was listening to the bird stories that you guys were telling from your own home. But I googled it and I found out that there was an article about why we're seeing dead birds and birds that are struggling now. It's because of quarantine. It was the most interesting article. They said that we are just around and we're noticing nature more and we're more aware because we're not like in our offices all day long. So that unfortunately this is a time where birds struggle, but we don't usually see it. So I don't know. That's like yay or boo or somewhere in between. But no, this is the big bird baby boom season this
因为我确信那就是，我能想象得到，我脑海里有那个画面。我想告诉你的是，当我听到你们讲自己家里发生的小鸟故事时。我谷歌了一下，然后我发现了一篇关于为什么我们现在看到死鸟和苦苦挣扎的小鸟的文章。这是因为隔离。这是一篇非常有趣的文章。他们说我们只是四处走动，更多地注意到大自然，而且我们更有意识，因为我们不是一整天都呆在办公室里。所以不幸的是，这是一个鸟类苦挣扎的时期，但我们通常看不到。所以，我不知道。这算是一件好事还是坏事，或者介于两者之间。不过，不对，这是鸟类大生儿育女的季节，在
time of the year. And a big part of because I looked it up to Jen, a big part of a bird's life cycle is that between the nest and being a full adult bird, they actually nest on the ground. So they the parents kind of kick them out of the tree. And they nest under bushes or on the ground for a couple of days. And their parents visit them. But it's sort of like that's like they're going to college phase, you know, they're out of the nest, but their parents are still kind of like sending a money from time to time. And so in that little period, like 80% of birds die because they are, you know, peril meets them. Maybe it's, you know, a raccoon or a cat or something a squirrel. Yeah, this is the part of their
每年的这个时候，因为我查过了，简，鸟类生命周期很大的一部分是，在离开鸟巢和成为完全成年的鸟之间，它们实际上是在地面上筑巢的。所以它们的父母有点像把它们赶出树。它们在灌木丛下或地面上筑巢几天。它们的父母会来看望它们。但这有点像是它们的上大学阶段，你知道的，它们离开了鸟巢，但它们的父母仍然会不时地给它们寄钱。所以在那个小小的时期里，大约 80% 的鸟类会死去，因为它们，你知道的，危险迎面而来。也许是，你知道的，浣熊、猫或者某种松鼠。是的，这是它们
life that where they meet the most doom. Oh, this is sad. But I read that somebody rescued another person like a bird fell into a pool, but they rescued it. So it's like there may be more rescues happening because we're more aware and vigilant right now next year, an article that says a rise in birds due to people intervening and has now bled us of all of the gnats. And it turns out gnats were necessary. I know this is Benny on a Christmas and I'm sure you will deal with this. But like, I do remember reading articles that people's lives were saved because of being alive in the safety training as a safety training in the episode where I'm specially
生命中最常遭遇劫难的部分。哦，这太让人难过了。但我读到有人救了另一个人，比如一只鸟掉进了泳池，但他们救了它。所以这就好像因为我们现在更加警觉和有防范意识，可能会有更多的救援发生，明年，就会有一篇文章说，由于人们的干预，鸟类数量增加，现在把我们的小咬都吸干了。事实证明，小咬是必不可少的。我知道这是圣诞节的一集，我确信你们会处理这个。但是，我确实记得读过一些文章，说人们的生命因为经历了安全培训而获救，就像那一集里作为安全培训的
stretch relief. Yeah, because I remember I wrote that I wrote that and I remember having to make sure I remember wanting to make sure it was correct in case anybody watched the show and actually use it. But then I started to hear news reports that people remember it from the office and are saving people's lives from that. I've read those same articles. It's crazy. You're saving lives, Jen Salada. Well, I don't know. Jen, we always like to ask people when they come on the podcast how they got their job
呼吸急救法。对，因为我记得我写过那个，我记得我必须确保，我记得我想确保它是正确的，以防任何人看节目并真正使用它。但随后我开始听到新闻报道，说人们从《办公室》里记住了这一点，并用它来拯救人们的生命。我也读过那些相同的文章。太疯狂了。你在拯救生命，简·萨拉达。好吧，我不知道。简，我们总是喜欢在人们来到播客时问他们是如何找到这份工作的
on the office. I was on the show Malcolm in the Middle, which I really enjoyed that show. But I every every morning after the after the office aired, I would come in and just talk about the office forever. And they were like, let's get to work on Malcolm stories. And I was like, yeah, yeah, sure. Did you see what happened on diversity day? So I was a big fan. And I actually wrote a short story about a woman falls in love with the middle of a man. She works in quality control in a button factory and she sees the middle of people walking by a window all day long and she puts all her hopes and dreams in the middle of this man. And oh my God, I love that. That is brilliant.
在《办公室》里。我曾在《马尔科姆的一家》节目组，我真的很喜欢那个节目。但我每天，在《办公室》播出后的每天早上，我都会来这里，没完没了地谈论《办公室》。他们就会说，让我们开始干马尔科姆的故事吧。而我会说，对，对，当然。你看到多元化日发生的事了吗？所以我是一个铁杆粉丝。我实际上写过一篇短篇小说，讲的是一个女人爱上了一个男人的中间部分。她在一家纽扣厂做质量控制，她整天看着人们的中间部分从窗前走过，她把所有的希望和梦想都寄托在这个男人的中间部分上。哦，天哪，我喜欢这个。这太绝了。
It was so crazy. I had never written a short story before. I wrote it. It took me forever to write it because I took me forever to sit down and figure out what I had to say if any did I have anything to say? And it kind of anyway, I wrote it. And then Suzanne Daniels, I found out that they have piles of scripts. The Daniels house has piles of scripts to the point where the kids have told me that they almost forget that their scripts they think of them as furniture, like a coffee table somewhere to put their legs up. And Suzanne Daniels, I guess, grabbed my short story, probably thinner than the rest of the scripts on the pile and responded to it and gave it to Greg. And then I met him at a coffee
这太疯狂了。我以前从未写过短篇小说。我把它写了下来。这花了我好长好长时间才写完，因为我花了超级久才坐下来弄清楚我要说什么，如果，我有话要说吗？不管怎样，我把它写了下来。然后苏珊·丹尼尔斯（Suzanne Daniels），我发现他们有一堆堆的剧本。丹尼尔斯家有成堆的剧本，以至于孩子们告诉我，他们几乎忘了那是剧本，他们把它们当成家具，比如某个可以把腿放上去的咖啡桌。我想苏珊·丹尼尔斯抓起了我的短篇小说，它可能比那一堆里的其他剧本都要薄，并且给出了回复，把它交给了格雷格（Greg）。然后我在咖啡豆
bean had a meeting right before he was about to go to up front for season two. And it just probably begged to be on the show was really excited and just loved him, loved meeting him. And that's how it happened. Oh my gosh. That is such a fantastic story. Well, Jen, we have a question for you about, you know, obviously, we're talking Benihana Christmas today. What was the inspiration for this episode? Do you remember how it came about how you came to be the person to write it? Like, sort of the beginning of what was Benihana? The initial idea was Michael goes through a breakup. And I can almost see myself leaping out of a chair at that moment. If that came when I came from the room saying this, I need to
咖啡馆见了他，就在他准备去参加第二季的推介会之前开了一个会。我当时可能在恳求加入这个剧组，真的超级兴奋，而且太喜欢他了，喜欢见他。事情就是这样发生的。哦，天哪。这真是一个太棒的故事了。好吧，简，我们有一个关于，你知道的，显然我们今天在谈论《班尼哈那的圣诞节》（Benihana Christmas）。这一集的灵感是什么？你还记得它是怎么出炉的吗？你是怎么成为这一集的编剧的？比如，班尼哈那最初是怎么来的？最初的想法是迈克尔经历了一次分手。我几乎能看到自己在那个时刻从椅子上跳起来。如果那来自我在编剧室里说出这话的时候，我需要
have this episode because I just felt like taking Michael through a breakup is just like having how would a 14 year old boy deal with a breakup, you know, just kind of just riding those waves for the first time. Has he ever been that close to a person to have, you know, to a romantic partner to have those waves so you can really take him to the point where he's lying on the floor. So I put in a little bit of 14 year old boy and then a little bit of me, you know, listening to James Blunt goodbye my lover and breakups that I can't understand. So there was a smush of the two of us, my version of Michael stuff. And when I ended up leaving the office, which is devastatingly difficult to do, but I ended up telling Steve
拥有这一集，因为我只是觉得让迈克尔经历一次分手，就像是，一个 14 岁的男孩会如何处理分手呢？你知道的，就是第一次去经历那些情绪的起伏。他以前曾和一个人的距离如此之近，和一个浪漫伴侣如此之近，以至于有过那些情绪起伏，所以你可以真正带他走到他躺在地上的地步。所以我融入了一点点 14 岁男孩的特质，然后又融入了一点点我自己的特质，你知道的，听着詹姆斯·布朗特（James Blunt）的《Goodbye My Lover》，还有那些我无法理解的分手。所以这是我们两人的融合，我版本的迈克尔的戏码。当我最终离开《办公室》时——这真的是毁灭性地艰难——但我最后告诉了史蒂夫（Steve）
that I was leaving and his I'll never forget his comment to me. He said, I think this is going to be really difficult for you. And I said, Yeah, no, definitely. But he's like, because I think you work a lot of your own stuff out through my character. I was like, there's this game that people play of who are they in the office. And I'm like, I can't be Pam or Angela or Phyllis like, I'm Michael. Michael thinks I'm Michael. Steve was aware Steve was aware when it was a genselotta script. Oh, well, we're going to work out some issues this week. Yes. So I, I think that for the breakup, I put myself as being sort of delayed in that area and experiencing a breakup. I think my first breakup with a boyfriend was
我要离开，我对他的评价我永远不会忘。他说，我觉得这会对你非常困难。我说，对，不，绝对的。但他却说，因为我觉得你通过我的角色解决了许多你自己的问题。我就觉得，人们会玩这样一个游戏，即他们是办公室里的谁。而我心想，我不能当帕姆、安吉拉或菲利斯——我是迈克尔。迈克尔认为我是迈克尔。史蒂夫是心知肚明的，当这是一个简·萨拉达的剧本时，史蒂夫是心知肚明的。哦，好吧，我们这周要解决一些问题了。是的。所以，我，我想对于分手这件事，我把自己放在了那个领域里有些迟钝并经历着分手的状态中。我想我跟男友的第一次分手是在
late, you know, mid twenties, you know, just experiencing that. And then also just having, you know, just thinking of a young, a younger boy going through it. And I just let I wanted it so badly. So I think I probably just wrestled someone to the ground. Oh my God. Well, Jen, I would love to talk to you about the party planning committee versus the committee to plan parties. What the hell? You were saying on a previous podcast, Jenna, that I really am drawn to Angela and writing for Angela. And there was something, I was starting to think about why that was beside just being brilliant. And it's so funny. And it's just fun to write for you. But I was thinking, I can't stand sometimes rules and bureaucracy
很晚的时候，你知道的，二十岁出头到中旬，你知道的，只是去经历那种感受。然后还有，只是想着一个年轻的、正在经历这一切的年轻男孩。我是那么地渴望它。所以我想我可能只是把某个人扑倒在地了。哦，天哪。好吧，简，我很想和你聊聊派对策划委员会对阵策划派对委员会。到底怎么回事？詹娜，你之前在播客上说过，我真的被安吉拉吸引，并且喜欢为安吉拉写剧本。有一点，我开始思考这是为什么，除了她才华横溢之外。这太有趣了。而且为你写剧本很有趣。但我一直在想，我有有时真的无法忍受规章制度和官僚主义
and all of that stuff. And I feel like your character represented so many of those lines and things you can't do and limits. So somehow it was like cathartic for me to go deep in there and like, have you pushed those lines with people, you know, comedy writers oftentimes want to push against authority and rules. And so you were, you represented that. So I just kind of love to give you that. So then it's, what do you do to your character? You threaten her with a rival party and just kind of up the stakes, arrival, a planning committee and up the stakes and have you kind of lose it? When you run out to try to get the permission from Dwight that the party needs to start now, it's just like the intensity with which
以及所有那些东西。我觉得你的角色代表了那么多那样的界限、你不能做的事以及限制。所以不知何故，深入其中对我来说就像是一种宣泄，让你和人们一起打破那些界限，你知道的，喜剧编剧往往想要对抗权威和规则。所以你，你代表了这一点。所以我只是有点喜欢赋予你这些。然后就是，你对你的角色做了什么？你用一个竞争派对威胁她，有点拉高了赌注，一个竞争的策划委员会，拉高了赌注，让你有点失控？当你跑出去试图从德怀特（Dwight）那里获得派对需要现在开始的许可时，那种你紧紧抓住
you're clinging to the fact that you need to maintain the balance of your structure is like, I just, I just delayed in that. I remember that scene. I remember actually talking to you about the dialogue and you and Harold. And, and I guess the first take I did it, maybe I didn't have that urgency. Like, and, and you guys like pulled me aside and you're like, no, like, like, think like the building's on fire. Like, you know, and that kind of like stakes. And then while we're talking about this, I had a line where I said to Meredith as she's deciding which party to go to, I say, Meredith, like, if you go to that party, you're going to be very, very
需要维持你的结构平衡的强烈程度，就好像，我只是，我对此难以忘怀。我还记得那个场景。我还记得实际上跟你讨论过那段台词，你和哈罗德（Harold）。而且，我猜我拍第一条的时候，可能没有那种紧迫感。就像，而且，你们把我拉到一边，你们说，不，就像，想象大楼着火了一样。就像，你知道的，那种利害攸关的感觉。然后正当我们谈论这个时，我有这样一句台词，我对梅雷迪思（Meredith）说的，当时她正在决定去哪个派对，我对她说，梅雷迪思，如果你去那个派对，你会非常非常
sorry. And then Meredith is like, is that a threat? And I go, no, it's an invitation. I don't think I really got the joke on the first time I read it. And you're like, Angie, you like maybe when you say it's an invitation, switch gears to like a smile. And I remember it changed the whole scene. Like, I love that moment. That moment reminds me of in horror movies when like the deranged ex-boyfriend is like, and then then there's like silence and he's like, Monica, I'd love to come inside. And you're like, whoa, that is super creepy me. That's scarier than the banging on the door. So that's when I watch that scene, Angela. That's an invitation was like super unnerving was like, what just happened? That was a note.
遗憾的。然后梅雷迪思说，这是威胁吗？我回答说，不，这是邀请。我想我第一次读的时候并没有真正get到那个笑话。然后你们说，安吉（Angie），你可能在说“这是邀请”的时候，转换成一个微笑。我记得这改变了整个场景。我喜欢那个时刻。那个时刻让我想起恐怖电影里，那个精神错乱的前男友说，然后，然后是一片寂静，他说，莫妮卡（Monica），我很想进去。然后你会觉得，哇，这比砸门还要让人毛骨悚然。这比砰砰砸门更吓人。所以当我看到那一幕时，安吉拉。“这是邀请”那种感觉超级令人不安，就好像，刚刚发生了什么？这是一个笔记。
That was a note from Jen Solana. That's just a peek into her brain. Well, maybe there's definitely an alternate reality where the office is a horror and Angela. There are moments where you're standing by the copier and then just, you know, jump out. But I feel like there's something where you get to see Angela's struggle of her real feelings in the episode because they leak out all over the place. But then the pop back to this is a work. This is an office. We have to be professional. So there's like, we get to see that like moment where you where you the threat comes out. And then, you know, this is an office decorum. Here I am. It's so creepy because we just saw what you really are or what part
那是来自简·萨拉达的笔记。这只是对她大脑的一瞥。好吧，也许绝对存在这样一个平行现实：办公室是一个恐怖片，而安吉拉。有时你会站在复印机旁，然后，你知道的，突然跳出来。但我觉得有那么一个地方，你能在这集里看到安吉拉与真实情感的抗争，因为它们到处泄露出来。但随后又弹回了：这是一个工作场所。这是一个办公室。我们必须保持专业。所以这就好像，我们能看到那个你威胁脱口而出的瞬间。然后，你知道的，这是办公室的礼仪。我在这儿。这太毛骨悚然了，因为我们刚刚看到了你真实的样子，或者说你的某一部分
of you is. Oh, yeah. I love the storyline too, because it serves that whole purpose. And then it also serves the purpose of putting Pam and Karen together and freaking Jim out. So that's why I it's so rich with storyline. Should we head over to Benny Hanna because Jen, we were not there that day that you shot in the restaurant. And there are so many delicious scenes. Delicious. I feel like that was a really good use of, is that like a metaphor? Because Benny Hanna serves food? I don't know. Oh, well, I think that the idea of Benny Hanna might have come up because it always cheered me up when I was a kid. If I'd like been sick or if I could grade, we'd go to Benny Hanna. And I remember they used to like fling shrimp in your mouth.
是什么样的。哦，是的。我也很喜欢这个故事线，因为它服务于整个目标。然后它还起到了把帕姆和卡伦撮合到一起并把吉姆吓坏的作用。所以这就是为什么它拥有如此丰富的故事情节。我们要不要去班尼哈那？因为简，那天你们在餐厅拍摄的时候我们不在。有那么多美味的场景。美味。我觉得那是对什么的很好利用，那是个隐喻吗？因为班尼哈那是提供食物的？我不知道。哦，好吧，我想班尼哈那的想法可能是因为我小时候它总是能让我高兴起来。如果我生病了或者考得好，我们就会去班尼哈那。我记得他们会在你嘴里抛虾。
I heard that when I was doing research for this episode that they stopped doing that. I think that they were worried about it being dangerous. And so flinging hot shrimp across a restaurant. But Jen, I love to know like how Benny Hanna was like part of your childhood memory because our youngest son, when he turned eight, the one thing he wanted to do was go to Benny Hanna. Oh, yes. Well, it's like our eight year old's birthday. It's dinner and a show. Oh, I remember. So there was a scene where Dwight talks about the knife that the chef is using and how, oh, I bet you're bummed that you want this other knife. And the chef is saying, no, no, this knife is better. Dwight, you don't know what the best knife is. And I kind of put this
我听说在我为这一集做研究的时候，他们停止那样做了。我想他们是担心这会有危险。所以把热虾抛过餐厅。但是，简，我很想知道班尼哈那是如何成为你童年记忆的一部分的，因为我们的小儿子八岁时，他唯一想做的事就是去班尼哈那。哦，是的。好吧，就像我们八岁孩子的生日一样。这就是美食加表演。哦，我记得。所以有一个场景是德怀特谈论主厨正在使用的刀，以及，哦，我敢打赌你很遗憾你想要这把别的刀。主厨说，不，不，这把刀更好。德怀特，你根本不知道什么是最好的刀。我有点把这个
together when I was rewatching the episode. But when we were there, there was a problem making the onion volcano. So that was sort of the biggest pull up of the day. The chef couldn't make the onion volcano. And then they brought in another chef to make the onion volcano. We couldn't get an onion volcano off the ground. It was, and I think we had one of the more celebrated onion volcano chefs there. And what immediately happened to me, even though I wrote the scene with Dwight talking about knives, is I was like, well, maybe the, is the oven hot enough? Are you sure that the right positioning of the onions? I'm like, they know onion volcanoes. I don't know onion volcanoes, but we were desperately trying to get this. And so all of us were sitting around
组合在了一起，当我重看这一集的时候。但当我们到那儿时，制作洋葱火山出了问题。所以这可以说是那天最吸引人的一幕了。主厨做不出洋葱火山。然后他们请来了另一个主厨来做洋葱火山。我们怎么都弄不出一个洋葱火山。当时，而且我认为我们在那儿有一位最著名的洋葱火山主厨之一。我立刻产生的反应是，尽管我写了德怀特谈论刀具的场景，但我还是想，好吧，也许烤箱温度够不够？你确定洋葱摆放的位置对吗？我就想，他们懂洋葱火山。我不懂洋葱火山，但我们当时正拼命想弄好这个。所以我们所有人都坐在周围
giving notes to a person who was already in a difficult time making the onion volcano, trying to get help, you know, how can we help this? So secret little fun fact, the steam from the onion was added in post because we've never, the volcano never erupted on the day. There was, I think, a fluttering of smoke that came out after I want to say hours of trying to get this off the ground. And I think it was Dean Holland who was editing the episode. He's like, here's what we're going to do. We're going to add some, we're going to add some smoke to the onion. We can do this. And I, I can just imagine my past Jen crying at that moment of relief because the onion sputtering would not lift up a heartbroken Michael. And, you know, we needed,
给这个正在制作洋葱火山、度过艰难时期的人提出建议，试图获得帮助，你知道的，我们怎么能帮上忙呢？所以，有个秘密小趣闻，洋葱散发出的蒸汽其实是后期加进去的，因为那天火山根本就没有喷发。我记得，在尝试了无数小时之后，才飘出了一缕青烟。我猜是剪辑这集的迪恩·霍兰说，好吧，我们这么办。我们要加点烟，我们要给洋葱加点烟。我们可以做到。我，我完全能想象出过去的珍在松了一口气的瞬间喜极而泣，因为洋葱滋滋冒出的蒸汽可没办法抚慰心碎的迈克尔，而且，你知道的，我们需要
we needed that onion to do its part. Yes. Yes. Oh my gosh, I love that story so much. So Jen, now we want to talk about the storyline with the Benihana waitresses and how Michael can't tell them apart. And I know we traded emails about this, even though we're saying, Michael, you should know better what you're doing is wrong. Is it even right to put that storyline out there? Can you share your reaction to rewatching it? You know, it's like, I feel conflicted about the whole, like there was this like Archie Bunker, Michael Scott, David Brents thing that we would make a joke that this is clearly inappropriate. But some of that stuff is just not appropriate, even if it's being made a joke. Fun of, and some
我们需要那个洋葱发挥它的作用。是的。是的。哦天哪，我太喜欢这个故事了。那么，珍，现在我们想谈谈贝尼哈纳（Benihana）女服务员的剧情线，以及迈克尔怎么也分不清她们。我知道我们为此交换过电子邮件，尽管我们在说，迈克尔，你本该更懂事，你做的事是错的。把这条剧情线播出来真的合适吗？你能分享一下重新观看时的反应吗？你知道的，这就像是，我对整件事感到矛盾，比如说，有一种阿奇·邦克（Archie Bunker）、迈克尔·斯科特、大卫·布伦特式的风格，我们会开玩笑说这明显是不合适的。但其中有些内容就是不合适的，哪怕它们被当成了笑料
is, and I don't know where some of the line is, but what is, what is offensive, what is going to hurt somebody? What is making fun of a character who does this? And is that even okay? Or where's the line for that? We're constantly growing and, and, and have to understand, you know, even if our intention was to do something to show how ridiculous this behavior is at the time, how does that portrayal come across? And is that affecting people and just taking it all in and just trying to educate myself as much as I can about how, what we put out there affects people. Yeah, absolutely. I feel like as a creative community, we need to learn and, and reevaluate how we tell stories. Yeah. And, and like you said, Jen, how those stories affect people.
取笑，而且有些内容确实如此，我不知道界限在哪里，但什么是冒犯，什么是会伤害别人的？什么是对做出这种行为的角色的取笑？这甚至可以接受吗？或者是这条界限在哪里？我们一直在成长，并且必须明白，你知道的，即使我们当时的初衷是想做点什么来展现这种行为有多荒谬，这种 portrayal（刻画）呈现出来的效果是怎样的？这会不会对人们产生影响，把这一切都吸收进去，然后试着尽可能多地自我教育，了解我们放出的内容是如何影响人们的。是的，绝对是。我觉得作为一个创意社区，我们需要学习并重新评估我们是如何讲故事的。是的，就像你说的，珍，那些故事是如何影响人们的。
Yeah. Yeah. All right, Jen, well, before you go, can we ask you just a couple of quick little questions about this episode? Okay, first of all, everyone wants to know, is there a significance to Jim and Karen both giving one another a copy of Bridget Jones' diary? Is there a story there? I, as far as I remember, it was that they saw it together. I don't think they were fans of it, and they kind of gave it to each other as sort of a joke gift. I remember we were talking about they wouldn't be giving each other a really significant gift, right? At this point, it's not like a really big gift. But at the same time, it should be a gift that if Pam is watching will feel like, Oh God, they're on the same wavelength. So it was like, you don't want, you know, him to
好吧，珍，在你离开之前，我们能就这集问你几个简单的小问题吗？好的，首先，每个人都想知道，吉姆和凯伦互相赠送一本《布里奇特·琼斯日记》（Bridget Jones's Diary）有什么特别的含义吗？这里面有什么故事吗？据我所记得的，是因为他们一起看过这部电影。我觉得他们算不上粉丝，他们把书送给对方算是一种开玩笑的礼物。我记得我们当时讨论过，他们不会送对方一份真正意义重大的礼物，对吧？在这个节点上，这算不上什么大礼。但与此同时，它应该是一份让帕姆看到就会觉得，“天哪，他们太有默契了”的礼物。所以这就变成了，你既不希望他
give her jewelry, but at the same time, you don't want just two different gifts where it's just, you know, a for just the efficiency of a script where they have to both be explained. Why does this mean something? Why does this mean something? So it was a quick way to sort of say, they're on a similar wavelength, but it's not a real serious gift. There was a debate between Mindy and Mike about that movie, because Mindy would talk about her classic comedy movies, and this is more about her age. She, you know, would say Bridget Jones is like a classic comedy, and Mike would probably talk about, I can't remember the examples of the apartment or like, just sure. Right. So Mindy got Mike, a Bridget Jones diary poster and signed it,
送她珠宝，但与此同时，你也不希望仅仅送两件不同的礼物，结果仅仅是为了剧本的高效，还得双双解释：为什么这个有意义？为什么那个有意义？所以这是一个委婉的方式，用来表达他们很有默契，但这并不是一份极其严肃的礼物。明迪和迈克关于那部电影曾有过一番争论，因为明迪会谈论她那些经典的喜剧电影，而这部电影更符合她的年龄。她，你知道的，会说《布里奇特·琼斯》是一部经典喜剧，而迈克可能会谈论——我不记得例子了——比如《公寓春光》（The Apartment）或者类似的，对吧。所以明迪给迈克买了一张《布里奇特·琼斯日记》的海报并在上面签了名，
and Mike hung it on his wall. So I think the fact that it was a bit of a joke between Mike and Mindy, it ended up getting that was the specific that we use. So it wasn't just let's make fun of a movie that's super popular and great. Angela, you wanted to ask about karaoke. I did. I wanted to ask you, Jen, how you guys decided on the songs that each character would sing. Kevin sings, you ought to know, by Alanis Morcette. Michael and Andy sing, Your Body is a Wonderland, John Mayer. Kelly sings We Belong, which is hilarious by Pat Benatar. Creed sings his own song Spinning and Reeling. And then of course Dwight sings Lady by Sticks. Yes. So all right. I remember We Belong, definitely me, because I came up with that because I, as soon as I like
迈克把它挂在了墙上。所以我觉得，既然这是迈克和明迪之间的一个小玩笑，最终我们采用的就是这个细节。所以这不仅仅是拿一部超级受欢迎又很棒的电影开玩笑。安吉拉，你想问关于卡拉OK的事。是的。我想问你，珍，你们是怎么决定每个角色唱什么歌的？凯文唱的是阿兰妮斯·莫里塞特（Alanis Morissette）的《You Ought to Know》。迈克尔和安迪唱的是约翰·梅尔（John Mayer）的《Your Body Is a Wonderland》。凯莉唱的是帕特·贝塔特（Pat Benatar）的《We Belong》，这太搞笑。克里德唱的是他自己的歌《Spinning and Reeling》。然后当然，德 Dwight 唱的是斯蒂克斯乐队（Styx）的《Lady》。是的。所以，好吧。我记得《We Belong》绝对是我提议的，因为我想出来的，因为我一
the guy, I would start singing that in the shower. That is me. That is where me and the Kelly Kapoor character collide. However, I am 99% sure it was Mindy that said, We Belong Together, Ryan. But I did not have that in my comment. I just had her singing. It's genius. It makes the moment. It's so good. I just looked up. I had in my writer's first draft, Kevin singing, one second please, Mo Money Mo Problems by Notorious B.I.G. instead of Alanis Morcette. So somehow during the rewrite process, it became You Want to Know, which is just fantastic, where he just goes for it at the end. I watched that scene and I noticed, I don't know if it's Jim or if it's John, where you see him laughing and smiling at Brian. It feels like he's breaking,
喜欢上哪个男生，我就会在淋浴时开始唱这首歌。那就是我。这就是我和凯莉·卡普尔这个角色重合的地方。不过，我有99%的把握是明迪说：“我们属于彼此，瑞恩（We Belong Together, Ryan）。”但我评论里没记这个。我只记了她唱歌。这太天才了。这成就了这个高光时刻。太棒了。我刚刚查了一下，我在编剧的第一版初稿里，凯文唱的是——请等一下——是声名狼藉先生（The Notorious B.I.G.）的《Mo Money Mo Problems》，而不是阿兰妮斯·莫里塞特的歌。所以不知怎的，在重写剧本的过程中，它变成了《You Ought to Know》，这简直太棒了，他最后完全是豁出去了。我看了那场戏，我注意到，我不知道那是吉姆还是约翰，你能看到他在看着布赖恩时笑了起来。感觉他快要笑场了，
but I agree. I wrote it in a tiny code and everything. He's clearly breaking. You can see his cheeks bulging and that's why he doesn't turn around. He's like fixated on Kevin because John is breaking. That's amazing. And I do remember we wanted Creed to sing one of his own songs. We just thought that was incredible. What a cool opportunity. How often do we have that? Dude was in a band. He was in a band. He's phenomenal. I was going to say one thing that's in another song thing, but not from here. I wrote a joke where Michael says, I got two tickets to Paradise. He says, pack your bags. We leave the day after tomorrow. And at the Sound Mix, I found out from Kent that that was a $60,000 joke. I was like, it's a fine joke. None of my jokes I've ever written
但我同意。我还用极小的代号把它写下来了之类的。他明显是在笑场。你可以看到他的面颊鼓起来了，这就是为什么他不转过身去。他就像是死死盯着凯文，因为约翰正在笑场。这太棒了。我确实记得我们想让克里德唱他自己的歌之一。我们只是觉得这太不可思议了。多么酷的机会。我们有多经常能有这种机会？这家伙以前组过乐队。他组过乐队。他太厉害了。我正想说一件事，是关于另一首歌的，但不是这集的。我写过一个笑话，迈克尔说，我买了两张去天堂的票。他说，收拾好行李。我们后天出发。在混音时，我从肯特那里得知那是一个价值六万美元的笑话。我当时想，这倒是个不错的笑话。我写过的所有笑话里，
have been a $60,000 joke. But I remember not so long after that, we had some of our music budget pulled away from us. And I can't help but think, I mean, I was sitting at the mix and had no idea that because he's saying that song, that song had to be cleared. And that joke was $60,000. Jen Salado, you're such a delight. I just enjoy you so much. And we just want you to come back as many times as you will, please. Oh, I mean, it's so much fun. It's so much fun. All right, Jen, thank you so much. Thank you so much, Jen. Okay, we are back. Let's break down the rest of this episode. We are at the Hibachi table and Dwight is decided that he knows more about knives than the Benihana chef. Yeah, he's sort of like, ooh, is that a Nakiri? And the chef is like, no,
从来没有哪个是价值六万美元的笑话。但我记得在那之后不久，我们的一部分音乐预算就被削减了。我不禁在想，我是说，当时我坐在混音室里，完全不知道就因为他唱了那首歌，那首歌必须获得版权许可。而那个笑话价值六万美元。珍·萨拉多（Jen Salado），你太招人喜欢了。我太喜欢你了。我们只想让你只要愿意就多来几次，求你了。哦，我是说，这太有趣了。这真的太有趣了。好了，珍，非常感谢你。非常感谢你，珍。好的，我们回来了。让我们来剖析这集的剩余部分。我们来到了铁板烧桌旁，德怀特坚信他比贝尼哈纳的厨师更懂刀具。是的，他有点像是，噢，那是菜切刀（Nakiri）吗？然后厨师说，不，
it's a soba. And Dwight's like, oh, I bet you wish you had a Nakiri. And the chef's like, actually, this is better for large quantities. Yeah. And Dwight's like, I'm not sure. And then I, I wrote down a restaurant lady sass. I love this moment so much. And the actress's name is Annie Surtick. And she says, I think he would know. And then they look at each other, they like glare at each other. But I loved the way she delivered that line. Also want to give a shout out to the chef in the scene who I believe was a real Benihana chef. That's what Kent told us. I also noticed this is his only credit on IMDb. He also really knew what he was doing. And his name is Chatri Yovizetsak. Good job schooling Dwight Chatri. Exactly. Well, there's a deleted scene that happens right here,
这是荞麦面刀（soba）。德怀特就说，噢，我打赌你希望自己有一把菜切刀。厨师说，实际上，这把更适合大批量制作。是的。然后德怀特说，我不太确定。接着我，我记下了“餐馆女士的傲慢”（restaurant lady sass）。我太喜欢这个时刻了。这位女演员的名字叫安妮·瑟蒂克（Annie Sertic）。她说，我想他会知道的。然后他们对视了一眼，他们狠狠地瞪了彼此一眼。但我特别喜欢她台词的语气。还要对场景里的厨师大声表扬一下，我相信他真的是个贝尼哈纳的厨师。肯特就是这么告诉我们的。我还注意到这是他在IMDb上的唯一演艺履历。他确实知道自己在干什么。他的名字叫查特里·约维泽萨克（Chatri Yovizetsak）。干得漂亮，给德怀特上了一课，查特里。没错。嗯，这里有一段被删减的场景，
Jenna. And it's so good. Michael sneaks off to call Carol. And he asks her what he did wrong. And he's on the phone for a long time. And then he says, well, all right, could you tell me something that I did right? And then she hangs up. Oh, no. Oh, oh, that's crushing. But just watching Steve as Michael play the moment where he's listening to her rant. And he's like, okay, well, did I do anything right? It was really funny. After that phone call, is that when he would go back to the table and then Andy's trying to cheer him up? Yes, exactly. And then Andy's like, let's get around to drinks going, you know, and he tells him about this smoking volcano onion that's going to come. So that he comes back from the call really dejected. Ah, and this is what we talked about
珍娜。而且太棒了。迈克尔偷偷跑去给卡罗尔打电话。他问她自己做错了什么。他在电话里聊了很久。然后他说，好吧，好吧，你能告诉我有哪件事是我做对了吗？接着她就挂了电话。哦，不。哦，噢，这太令人心碎了。但光是看着史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔在听她长篇大论时的表现，那种神情，他说，好吧，那我有没有做对什么事？这真的太搞笑了。在这通电话之后，是不是就是他回到桌旁，然后安迪试图让他振作起来的时候？是的，完全正确。然后安迪就说，我们来点几杯饮料吧，你知道的，他跟他说会有一个冒烟的洋葱火山送上来。所以他打完电话回来时非常沮丧。啊，这就是我们在
in the interview with Jen about the steam from the onion. I tracked it. It's 21 minutes 44 seconds. If you want to see a real good shot of some fake onion steam, I tracked it too. Look, I have my timecode and everything. I got really excited. Okay, where are we? Oh, well, we're back. We're back at Scranton. And Pam and Karen have announced that their party is starting. And this is when Angela starts to spiral out. And she's like, I have a very important announcement. And she's trying to like make sure her party starts before theirs. Yes. And then this is when Angela calls Dwight. And she announces that her party started early. And it's also here. I tracked this Angela because we talked about this with Jen as well. At 20 minutes 50 seconds. This is that scene
采访珍时谈到有关洋葱蒸汽的话题。我找到了。是在21分44秒。如果你想看一眼非常逼真的假洋葱蒸汽镜头的话，我也找到了。看，我有我的时间码和一切。我当时超级兴奋。好吧，我们到哪儿去了？噢，好吧，我们回来了。我们回到了斯克兰顿。帕姆和卡伦宣布她们的派对要开始了。也就是这个时候，安吉拉开始情绪失控。她就像是，我有一个非常重要的通知。她试图确保她的派对在她们的派对开始之前开始。是的。然后这就是安吉拉打电话给德怀特的时候。她宣布她的派对提前开始了。也是在这里，我记录下了这个安吉拉，因为我们跟珍也聊过这个。在20分50秒。这就是那个场景，
where you say, it's an invitation. Yeah. That was right there. It's an invitation. That's when you see how Angela Martin would be in a horror movie. Well, also in this scene, we didn't talk about with Jen at 23 minutes 20 seconds. There is a really good shot of my gray tights that I'm wearing instead of pantyhose. That's all. That's all. Well, Jenna, I have something that I got really excited about. This is a great background catch for my folks that love the background like I do. I mean, I froze it. I took a picture of it. I'm very excited. At 23 minutes 10 seconds. In the deep background, Andy's screen and accounting looks like someone was surfing the internet. Zoom in. So then at 23 minutes 28 seconds, there is a picture of a cat with a cowboy hat
你说道，这是一份邀请。是的，就在那里。这是一份邀请。就在那时，你能看出安吉拉·马丁如果在恐怖电影里会是什么样。嗯，也是在这个场景里，我们在23分20秒时没有跟珍聊到。有一个非常清晰的镜头拍到了我穿的灰色紧身裤，我穿的是这个而不是连裤袜。就这样。就这样。好吧，珍，我有一件让我超级兴奋的事。对于喜欢背景细节的朋友们来说，这是一个绝佳的背景彩蛋，就像我一样。我是说，我把画面定格了。我拍了张照片。我超级兴奋。在23分10秒。在远景背景中，安迪在会计部的屏幕看起来像是在网上冲浪。放大。然后在23分28秒，
screensaver on Andy's computer. I want to say Angela, this same thing happens in the cold open when Dwight comes in with the goose. I am surfing the internet. And then the next shot when you see me at my desk, I have changed it to a screensaver. We were really surfing the internet in this episode clearly. What happened? We were just like there like, you know, paying our bills and shopping. So now Angela has announced that her party is starting. Do you know who the very first person to go to the other party is? Stanley. He stands there for a long time and looks back and forth and then picks Karen and Pam's party and he gives a look to camera. Is this Stanley's first like direct look to camera? Yes, I think it is. Yeah, I think it is. I also want to say Stanley,
安迪的电脑屏幕保护程序上有一张戴着牛仔帽的猫的照片。我想说，安吉拉，在冷开场里当德怀特带着大雁走进来时，也发生了同样的事。我在网上冲浪。然后下一个镜头当你看到我坐在办公桌前时，我已经把它换成屏保了。我们在这一集里显然真的在网上冲浪了。发生了什么？我们当时就像是在那儿，你知道的，付账单和购物。所以现在安吉拉宣布她的派对要开始了。你知道去参加另一个派对的第一个人是谁吗？斯坦利。他在那里站了很久，左右看了看，然后选择了卡伦和帕姆的派对，他还朝镜头看了一眼。这是斯坦利第一次直接看镜头吗？是的，我想是的。是的，我猜是的。我还想说，斯坦利，
what were you mulling over? I mean, what took so long? There was there was a chance you were ever going to go to Angela's party? A lot of suspense. Well, he might have to put up with Phyllis, you know, because you know Phyllis is going to my party. So maybe maybe it was more layered of a decision. Alright, so here's a breakdown of who goes to Karen and Pam's party. You have Stanley and you have Kelly and Ryan and Meredith. And then later we see that Daryl and Roy and Creed are all there as well. The only people that go to Angela's party are Hannah, who's by the way really snarky. She's so snarky and Kevin and Phyllis. Yeah, but then Kevin is going to leave your party and come to my party. I know, I know, we'll get to it. Something I want to point out
你到底在琢磨什么？我是说，怎么花了那么长时间？难道你有一秒钟真的打算去安吉拉的派对吗？真是悬念迭起。嗯，他可能得忍受菲利斯，你知道的，因为你知道菲利斯要去我的派对。所以也许，也许这是一个更多层的决定。好吧，所以这里是去参加卡伦和帕姆派对的人员名单。有斯坦利，还有凯莉、瑞恩和梅雷迪思。然后后来我们看到达里尔、罗伊和克里德也都在那里。唯一去安吉拉派对的人是汉娜，顺便说一句，她真的很刻薄。她太刻薄了，还有凯文和菲利斯。是的，但接着凯文要离开你的派对，来我的派对。我知道，我知道，我们一会儿会聊到。我想向大家指出的一件事是，
to everyone is that there is this huge Pam, Karen, Angela stare off, right? Yeah, yeah. It is for nine seconds. That's nine seconds of dead airtime. It starts at 24 minutes, 30 seconds. It goes to 24 minutes, 39 seconds. And I don't know why, but I wrote that's longer than you have to stay on a bull in like professional bull riding. You get eight seconds to stay on a bull. We stared at each other longer than you have to stay on a bull in professional bull riding. Well, Angela, I loved that you tracked our stare in bull riding seconds. I think that should be a new standard on our show. You're welcome. You're welcome. Is it longer or shorter than a bull ride? Well, Angela, this leads me into your talking head. It's so wonderful. You explain that you don't back down. It's a source of
这里有一场巨大的帕姆、卡伦和安吉拉的对峙，对吧？对，对。持续了九秒钟。那是整整九秒钟的静默时间。从24分30秒开始。一直持续到24分39秒。我不知道为什么，但我写道，这比你在职业骑牛比赛中必须坚持在公牛身上的时间还要长。你只有八秒钟的时间待在公牛身上。我们互相凝视的时间，比你在职业骑牛比赛中必须待在公牛身上的时间还要长。嗯，安吉拉，我喜欢你用骑牛的秒数来记录我们的凝视。我觉得这应该成为我们节目里的一个新标准。不客气。不客气。这比骑牛时间长还是短？嗯，安吉拉，这让我想到了你的单人访谈（talking head）。太精彩了。你解释说你绝不妥协。这是一种
pride. And in fact, you have not talked to your sister in 16 years because of an argument that you guys got into. You're that good. You don't even remember what the argument was about. Yeah. She's really proud of it. She's proud that she hasn't spoken to her sister. She doesn't even know why anymore. But she's not making that phone call. Well, we had a fan question. Okay. Hannah Mack, Lindsay Neame, Allie Burke, Veronica Ramirez and Jesse Clark all said, Angela says that her sister was her best friend, but they haven't spoken for 16 years. But then later, her sister Rachel appears at the end of the series in her bridal shower, where Angela describes them as being very close. Is this the same sister? Okay. I don't know what you have to say about it, Angela, but I have some
骄傲的源泉。事实上，你已经16年没跟你妹妹说过话了，就因为你们之间的一次争吵。你就是这么厉害。你甚至都不记得那场争吵是因为什么了。对。她对此感到非常自豪。她为自己16年没跟妹妹说话而感到自豪。她甚至都不记得原因了。但她绝不会打那通电话。好吧，我们有一个粉丝提问。好的。汉娜·麦克（Hannah Mack）、林赛·尼姆（Lindsay Neame）、艾莉·伯克（Allie Burke）、维罗妮卡·拉米雷斯（Veronica Ramirez）和杰西·克拉克（Jesse Clark）都说，安吉拉说她的妹妹曾是她最好的朋友，但她们已经16年没说过话了。但后来，她的妹妹蕾切尔（Rachel）在剧集结尾时出现在她的新娘送礼会（bridal shower）上，安吉拉在那里形容她们关系非常亲密。这是同一个妹妹吗？好吧。我不知道你对此有什么要说的，安吉拉，但我有一些
facts about it. What is your answer? No, no, I want to hear your facts. I looked it up in the show Bible. Oh, and here's what it said. Season five, episode 13, it is revealed that Angela has several sisters. So later at the wedding, we're referring to one of her sisters, Rachel. Although in the wedding, it sort of implies that you only have one sister again. So it is a little ambiguous. What's your story here, Ang? I always assumed that I had several siblings. You know, I have that line in the Martin family, we say looks like someone took the slow train to Philly. I just assumed there was more than just me and my parents, you know? Yeah. So I assumed I had more siblings and that the sibling at my wedding was not the one that I haven't spoken to. Unless she reached out to me,
关于这的事实。你的回答是什么？不，不，我想听听你的事实。我在剧集圣经（show Bible）里查过了。噢，上面是这么说的：第五季第13集，透露出安吉拉有几个姐妹。所以后来在婚礼上，我们指的是她的其中一个姐妹蕾切尔。虽然在婚礼上，它某种程度上又暗示了你只有一个姐妹。所以这有点模棱两可。安吉，你这到底是怎么回事？我一直以为我有好几个兄弟姐妹。你知道的，我在马丁家族里有那句台词，我们说“看起来就像有人坐了慢车去费城”。我只是以为除了我和我父母之外还有更多人，你知道的？是的。所以我以为我有更多的兄弟姐妹，而且我婚礼上的那个兄弟姐妹并不是我没跟她说话的那个人。除非她主动联系我，
I'm still not talking to her. Well, you made that clear in your talking head. Yes. That's for sure. All right. So should we go back to Benihana? Now, Michael is getting wasted, and he is going to steal some steak from a stranger's plate because he claims it's family style. And Jim is like, no, it's not. Jenna, this brings me to, I think we need to start tracking some drinks. Okay. I love it. If, if, how could we do this podcast without you tracking drinks? It's your favorite thing. Truly. It's like my purpose in life is to track these ridiculous things. So I'm going to take us back for a moment, but at 19 minutes, 40 seconds, that's when Andy orders the first round, right? Okay. Michael's come back from this phone call that we didn't know
否则我还是不跟她说话。好吧，你在单人访谈里把这一点表达得很清楚。是的。那是肯定的。好吧。那么我们应该回贝尼哈纳去吗？现在，迈克尔喝得酩酊大醉，他打算从一个陌生人的盘子里偷一块牛排，因为他声称那是家庭分享式（family style）的。而吉姆则说，不，才不是。珍娜，这让我想到了，我觉得我们需要开始记录一些饮料了。好的。我太喜欢了。如果，怎么能在没有你记录饮料的情况下做这个播客呢？这是你最喜欢的事。真的。这就像我生活中的目标，就是去记录这些荒唐的事情。所以我要把我们带回一会儿前，但在19分40秒，那是安迪点第一轮酒的时候，对吧？好的。迈克尔从我们不知道的那通电话里回来了。
about. And now Andy orders the first round. Andy, Michael and Dwight all get these cocktails. Jim gets what looks like to be like a Coca-Cola of some kind. It's like a brown looking soda. For my own peace of mind, I'm going to make Jim their designated driver. Go on. Oh, he 100% is. Okay. And then at 21 minutes, 25 seconds, you see Michael like downing his, he's like slamming it back. Then at 21 minutes, 31 seconds, Cindy is giving them a second round. Now she just gives it to Andy and Michael. I don't know about Dwight, but at 25 minutes, eight seconds, there's two more drinks in front of Michael and Andy. So by my tracking, I think they've had at least three. Okay. So now we have the scene with the waitress where Andy is asking the waitress
现在安迪点了第一轮酒。安迪、迈克尔和德怀特都点了这些鸡尾酒。吉姆拿的看起来像是某种可口可乐。就像是棕色苏打水。为了我自己的心理安宁，我要把吉姆定为他们的指定代驾（designated driver）。继续。噢，他百分之百是。好的。然后在21分25秒，你看到迈克尔在猛灌他的酒，他一口气把它干了。接着在21分31秒，辛迪正在给他们上第二轮。现在她只给安迪和迈克尔拿了。我不知道德怀特有没有，但在25分08秒，迈克尔和安迪面前又多了两杯饮料。所以根据我的记录，我觉得他们至少喝了三杯。好的。现在我们有了女服务员的那个场景，安迪要求女服务员
to close her eyes and imagine her dream house and then describe it to him. And Dwight can't hear any of this. So he asked Jim to explain what's happening. Jim says, oh, she's trying to describe how to butcher a dead goose, but she can't figure it out. So then Dwight chimes in and it ends up being very creepy and random. And can I just say I was in food service. Guys, stop being pervy and weird. Yeah, just be cordial. Be cordial. I mean, when they asked her to close her eyes, like, did you see how many tables she had? She is so busy. She's probably in the weeds, getting everything out to all these tables. She doesn't have time to like humor some guy who wants to flirt. You're at a restaurant with chefs doing a whole food show for you. That's your
闭上眼睛，想象她的梦想之家，然后向他描述。而德怀特根本听不见这一切。所以他让吉姆解释发生了什么。吉姆说，哦，她正在试图描述如何宰杀一头死大雁，但她想不出来。于是德怀特插话了，结果这变得非常诡异和随性。我能说我曾经从事过餐饮服务吗？伙计们，别再那么猥琐和奇怪了。对，态度要温和点。态度要温和点。我是说，当他们让她闭上眼睛时，你看没看到她有多少桌要应接？她忙得要命。她可能正焦头烂额地把所有东西端给所有这些桌子呢。她可没空去迎合一个想调情的家伙。你在一家餐馆里，有厨师为你做整场美食秀。那是你的
entertainment. Leave your waitress alone. In general, leave your waitresses alone. Come on, everybody. Oh, but before we move on from this table scene, I want to give a shout out to the guest actress who plays the woman at the table. Yes, Annie Sertic, who gives Dwight so much sass. Yes. Guys, she's amazing. I feel like she's only got the one line to Dwight, but her expressions and all of her reactions during the scene are so great. And she is a company member at the groundlings. She's had recurring roles on Silicon Valley and two broke girls. And I did a deep dive on her IMDB and I found this little interesting bit of trivia, Angela. What? She was on Curb Your Enthusiasm where she played quote unquote buffet woman. And then she was on Cougar Town playing
娱乐。别去打扰你的女服务员。总而言之，别去打扰女服务员。拜托，各位。哦，但在我们离开这个桌子场景之前，我想向扮演桌旁女客人的客串女演员致敬。是的，安妮·瑟蒂克，她给了德怀特那么多的顶撞。是的。伙计们，她太棒了。我觉得她对德怀特只有一句台词，但她在场景中的所有表情和反应都太棒了。而且她是“笑匠剧团”（The Groundlings）的剧团成员。她曾在《硅谷》（Silicon Valley）和《破产姐妹》（2 Broke Girls）中出演过常驻角色。我对她的IMDb进行了深入挖掘，我发现了这样一个有趣的小八卦，安吉拉。什么？她曾出演《抑制热情》（Curb Your Enthusiasm），在里面扮演所谓的“自助餐女人”（buffet woman）。然后她又在《熟女镇》（Cougar Town）中扮演
female chef. I just thought it was interesting that she's had three guest roles involving food. I'm also really envious that she got to play buffet woman because... Oh, that's got the role of my dreams. Yes, exactly. All right, we're back now at the parties. Angela's is not going well. It's pretty boring. Phyllis is like desperate to get out of this party. She really is one of my favorite things in this whole episode. Her yearning to be at the other party is so brilliant. Phyllis is so brilliant. And there is a deleted scene that's great that really would have amplified this. She pours herself like a drink and it's like ginger ale. And she says, oh, there's not a lot of fizz in this. And she starts to make her way to the door. And I'm like, no, no, no. She goes,
“女厨师”。我只是觉得很有趣，她竟然演过三个跟食物有关的客串角色。我也真的很嫉妒她能演自助餐女人，因为……哦，那是我的梦想角色。是的，完全正确。好吧，我们现在回到了派对上。安吉拉的派对进行得不太顺利。挺无聊的。菲利斯简直急着想离开这个派对。她真的是我在这整集里最喜欢的角色之一。她渴望去参加另一个派对的心情太精彩了。菲利斯太精彩了。而且有一个被删减的场景非常棒，真的可以放大这一点。她给自己倒了一杯饮料，结果是姜汁汽水。她说，哦，这里面没什么气泡。然后她开始往门口走去。我就想，不，不，不。她去说，
I might should get some more ginger ale. And I'm like, no, no, no. And I block her from leaving. I was like, I'll go get it. You stay. That is amazing. But her, her, her reaction when she pours it. And she's like, there's not a lot of fizz. It's like, you see her plotting to get out of the conference room. Well, I also quite enjoyed in the scene. Hannah, if you look at her in the background, she is like really examining the napkins. She is giving your napkins like the third degree. I'm sorry, she's not going to stick around longer. Well, we'll get to that in future episodes. Yes. All right. Well, Pam and Karen's party is a big hit, except the karaoke machine won't work because they don't have the right cord. But don't worry, because Daryl is
我或许该去拿点更多的姜汁汽水。我就想，不，不，不。我挡住她不让她离开。我当时说，我去拿。你待着。这太神奇了。但她，她，她倒酒时的反应。她说，没什么气泡。就像是，你能看到她在密谋溜出会议室。嗯，我也挺喜欢这个场景中的汉娜。如果你在背景中看她，她真的在仔细检查餐巾纸。她对你的餐巾纸进行了三度盘问。抱歉，她可不会待太久。好吧，我们会在以后的剧集中聊到这个。好的。好吧，帕姆和卡伦的派对大获成功，除了卡拉OK机无法工作，因为他们没有合适的线缆。但别担心，因为达里尔
going to go get his keyboard. And then there's this scene that I absolutely love as Daryl walks past the conference room. He's like, Hey, when you're done with your meeting, there's a party in the break room. But it's the way Craig says it, because Craig is like, Hey guys, when you get done with your meeting, it's like he doesn't quite know what to call it. He's like a meeting. You should come to the break room because we're having an actual party. And I love it. And that's when at 28 minutes, 24 seconds, Phyllis is standing in the doorway and she's sort of gazing at the other party. And then Ryan comes to get his jacket. She's like, Are you cold? That'll help. Is it cold in there? You know what? That was an improv. That was not in script. Stop it.
要去拿他的键盘。然后有了这个我绝对喜爱的场景，当达里尔走过会议室时。他说，嘿，你们开完会后，休息室里有个派对。但克雷格说这话的方式很有趣，因为克雷格就像是，嘿，伙计们，等你们开完会，就像是他不太清楚该怎么称口。他就像是开个会。你们应该来休息室，因为我们在开真正的派对。我太喜欢了。就在那时，在24分28秒，菲利斯站在门口，她正凝视着另一个派对。然后瑞恩来拿他的外套。她说，你冷吗？那会有帮助的。里面冷吗？你知道吗？那是即兴发挥的。剧本里没有。住手。
Yes. Which part? The final line? It was scripted that Ryan would come and get his jacket. And that Phyllis just says something like, How, how is it in there? And then he's like, Huh? And that was the end of the scene. And then he walks away. So Phyllis being like, Maybe that'll help. Is it cold in there? That was Phyllis. Well, her, maybe that would help. Like about had me fall out of the chair. Her runner is just absolutely one of my favorites in this whole episode. So now the guys return from Benihana and they have brought waitresses with them. So we covered a little bit of the Benihana Waitress storyline with Jen, but we did not really talk about this. And we got a lot of fan questions from Emma Bloom, Kelsey Kay, Kayla Bass, Abby Roll, T'Nessa Lee, Samantha
真的吗？哪部分？最后一句？剧本里写的是瑞恩会来拿他的外套。然后菲利斯只是随便说了句类似“里面怎么样？”然后他就说，“啊？”场景到这里就结束了。然后他走开了。所以菲利斯说“也许那会有帮助。里面冷吗？”那是菲利斯自己加的。嗯，她的那个“也许那会有帮助”，简直差点让我从椅子上摔下去。她的这个包袱绝对是我在这整集里最喜欢的包袱之一。现在，小伙子们从贝尼哈纳回来了，他们还带了女服务员回来。所以我们和珍一起讨论了一点贝尼哈纳女服务员的剧情线，但我们并没有真正讨论过这个。我们收到了很多粉丝的提问，来自艾玛·布鲁姆（Emma Bloom）、凯尔西·凯（Kelsey Kay）、凯拉·巴斯（Kayla Bass）、艾比·罗尔（Abby Roll）、特内萨·李（T'Nessa Lee）、萨曼莎
Mundan, and many others want to know why do the actresses playing the Benihana waitresses change when Michael and Andy bring them back to the office? Is that supposed to feed into the ongoing joke that Michael and Andy can't tell them apart? So no. The idea here was simply that Michael and Andy couldn't land the original waitresses that they'd been flirting with all night. And then they managed to get these two younger kind of more naive waitresses to come back with them to the office. And in the script, it says Michael and Andy walk in not with Cindy and her hot friend, but with two other 20 to 25 year old Asian American waitresses. So the idea was that these two older sophisticated women would never go back to a party. But these two younger gals, college age
蒙丹（Samantha Mundan）以及许多其他人，他们想知道为什么迈克尔和迪安把她们带回办公室时，扮演贝尼哈纳女服务员的女演员换人了？这难道是为了呼应迈克尔和安迪分不清她们是谁的连环笑话吗？并没有。这里的想法很简单，就是迈克尔和安迪根本没能约到他们一整晚都在调情的原版女服务员。然后他们设法让另外两个年轻一点、更天真的女服务员跟他们一起回了办公室。剧本里写的是，迈克尔和安迪走进来时，带进来的不是辛迪和她性感的朋友，而是另外两个20到25岁的亚裔美国女服务员。所以当时的设想是，这两位年纪较大、成熟老练的女性绝不会回办公室派对。但这俩年轻姑娘，也就是大学年龄的
gals, would be like, Oh yeah, like free drinks, we'll go. Free drinks. Like they're more up for it. Yeah. Free drinks and Michael's like, and I have a present for you. It's a bicycle. Yes. And she's thrilled. She's like, I love it. Yeah. Well, I have a background catch at 29 minutes when they walk into the office. The girls have on a lot of makeup. And then at 29 minutes, 12 seconds later, no makeup. What happened? Well, Angela, a lot of other people notice this as well. Sonia Maria Raposa wrote in with a theory. Oh, she thinks that they appear with makeup at first, because that's how Michael perceives them to be because he's drunk. And then they appear with no makeup because that's what they truly look like. It's not the case. Jen did a little bit of a deep
姑娘，会觉得，“哦，太棒了，有免费饮料，我们去吧。”免费饮料。就像她们更愿意奉陪一样。对。有免费饮料，而且迈克尔说，“我还有个礼物要送你。是一辆自行车。”是的，她欣喜若狂。她说，“我太喜欢了。”是的。好吧，我在29分钟时有一个背景彩蛋，当他们走进办公室时。女孩们画了很浓的妆。然后到了29分12秒，之后就没化妆了。发生了什么？嗯，安吉拉，很多其他人也注意到了这一点。索尼娅·玛丽亚·拉波萨（Sonia Maria Raposa）写信提出了一个理论。哦，她认为她们一开始带着妆出现，因为那是迈克尔眼中的她们，因为他喝醉了。然后她们没有化妆出现，因为那是她们真实的模样。事实并非如此。珍做了一点深入
dive. And she actually found an interview that her and Greg did on an office panel about this exact thing. And she said basically it was a continuity error. Yeah, exactly. She was telling us that the first day that they worked, they put makeup on them, then they watched the dailies and they were like, well, wait, that doesn't really track for who they are in the show as their characters, these younger college girls. And, you know, they shouldn't look that sophisticated. So the next time they worked, they toned down, didn't have them have makeup on. So it was as simple as that. They really wanted to drive home this idea that these were college girls. To kind of further emphasize how ridiculous Michael's infatuation and belief that he's found
挖掘。她实际上找到了她和格雷格在一次关于办公室的小组讨论中接受的采访，谈的就是这件事。她基本上是说这是一个连续性错误。是的，完全正确。她告诉我们，她们上班的第一天，剧组给她们化了妆，然后他们看了样片，觉得“嗯，等等，这跟她们在剧中的角色设定不太符合，作为这些年轻的大学生，（她们不该这样）。”而且，“她们不该显得那么成熟。”所以她们下次上班时，剧组就把妆容淡化了，让她们不化妆。所以事情就是这么简单。他们真的想极力强化这些是女大学生的概念。为了进一步强调迈克尔的迷恋以及他觉得自己找到了
his true love is. Yeah. And Michael now starts going around the office and introducing Nikki as his new girlfriend. Everyone is like, girlfriend. Huh. Really? Well, they realized pretty quickly that Angela's party is super lame. And as they leave, Nikki takes one of Angela's decorations and Angela is ticked off. And she insults her with the Hello Kitty backpack line. It's just a horrible thing to say. And Michael wants to get Nikki away from Angela as soon as possible. So he takes her to the really fun party in the break room. We have Kevin singing karaoke. Yeah. Go to 31 minutes 14 seconds and please watch Ryan. It is the most animated I've ever seen him. He's like swaying back and forth, singing like, you gotta know. He's like so into it. I'm
真爱的那种信念有多荒谬。是的。然后迈克尔开始在办公室里转悠，把妮基介绍为他的新女友。每个人都觉得——女友？哈。真的吗？嗯，他们很快意识到安吉拉的派对超级逊。当她们离开时，妮基拿走了安吉拉的一个装饰品，安吉拉气坏了。她用“Hello Kitty双肩包”这句台词侮辱了她。这话说的太难听了。迈克尔想尽快把妮基带离安吉拉身边。所以他带她去了休息室里那个真正有趣的派对。我们看到凯文在唱卡拉OK。是的。转到31分14秒，请看着瑞恩。这是我见过他最情绪高涨的一次。他左右摇摆，唱着“你必须知道（you gotta know）”。他太投入了。我当时想，
like, what's happening, Ryan? Is he drunk too? Well, I did have a fan question from this scene. Okay. From Sasha Lara, who wants to know, does Craig Robinson play the keyboard in real life? Oh, Sasha. Yes, he does. He definitely does. Oh, he's phenomenal. Are you kidding? He's amazing. And in those scenes on the show, when Craig would get out the keyboard, it really did turn into a party. Like, that was really fun to shoot. Angela, I'm sorry that you weren't in there, but we were having an amazing time. And between takes Craig would play and we would sing and Kate would sing show tunes. And I mean, it was like, it was exactly as much fun as you would imagine it would be. I'm bummed I wasn't in that scene to be able to hang out with you
瑞恩怎么了？他喝醉了吗？嗯，我确实有一个关于这个场景的粉丝提问。好的。来自萨莎·拉拉（Sasha Lara），她想知道克雷格·鲁宾逊（Craig Robinson）现实生活中会弹键盘吗？哦，萨莎。是的，他会。他绝对会。噢，他太厉害了。开玩笑吗？他太棒了。在剧中那些场景里，当克雷格掏出键盘时，现场真的变成了一个派对。真的，拍摄过程太有趣了。安吉拉，我很抱歉你当时不在里面，但我们当时过得开心极了。而且在拍摄间隙，克雷格会弹奏，我们会唱歌，凯特会唱百老汇音乐剧选段。我是说，那真的是你想象中有多好玩，它就有多好玩。我很遗憾自己当时不在那个场景里，没能跟你们
guys like that. But I cherish the times we were all in the conference room. And if Craig for, you know, in the latter years, he was in the main office bullpen. And he and Kate would start singing and Ed, I have found a video on my phone. Oh my God, Jenna, it's us in the conference room. And they just start making up a song. And like, and everyone is singing. And it's so great. I love it. Those are some of my favorite memories. I'll text you the video. Lady, should we go back to your super sad party? No, I guess. Angela's having a horrible day, but a big thing happens here, which is that Dwight holds Angela's hand. I know. It's like a very, very small moment. She's holding her boombox in her lap. And they hold hands. Well, this is when
那样一起玩。但我也很珍惜我们大家都在会议室里的时光。如果克雷格在……你知道的，在后来的几年里，他坐在主办公室的大办公区里。他和凯特会开始唱歌，还有埃德，我在手机里找到了一段视频。哦天哪，珍娜，是我们俩在会议室里。他们开始即兴创作一首歌。而且，每个人都在唱。太棒了。这些是我最美好的回忆。我把视频发给你。女士们，我们要回到你那超级悲伤的派对吗？不，我想不。安吉拉今天过得很糟糕，但这里发生了一件大事，那就是德怀特握住了安吉拉的手。我知道。这就像是一个非常非常小的时刻。她把手提音响抱在腿上。然后他们握了手。好吧，这就是
then Karen enters and announces that Dwight won the raffle, which of course is like a super passive aggressive thing to try to lure Dwight into the fun of their party. And as Dwight is excitedly opening the gift, Pam kind of clocks Angela's sadness and pulls Karen aside and says, I feel kind of bad for Angela. Hold up. Did Dwight really not win the raffle? No, lady, we just did that to try to lure him to our party. This whole time. I mean, when did he have time to enter the raffle? I don't know. But this whole time, I thought he won the raffle. And I was like, oh my God, Dwight won the raffle. I mean, I always took it to be like another, like how we lured Kevin away from your party. This is how we were going to lure Dwight
卡伦进来宣布德怀特赢得了抽奖活动的时候，这当然是一种超级被动攻击（passive aggressive）的做法，试图引诱德怀特加入她们派对的乐趣中。正当德怀特兴奋地打开礼物时，帕姆注意到了安吉拉的伤心，把卡伦拉到一边说，“我其实有点为安吉拉感到难过。”等等。德怀特真的没有赢得抽奖吗？不，女士，我们做那件事只是为了试图引诱他来我们的派对。这一切都是假的。我是说，他什么时候有时间参加抽奖了？我不知道。但在这之前，我一直以为他赢了抽奖。我当时想，哦天哪，德怀特赢了抽奖。我是说，我一直以为这就像是另一件事，比如我们是怎么把凯文从你的派对上引开的。这就是我们打算把德怀特
away by coming into your party and like trying to poach him. Oh my God, main girls. Here I am, all naive thinking like way to go Dwight. I mean, I don't think he won the raffle. That was my take on it was that it was a little bit of a mean girls moment on Pam and Karen's part. But you get Karen to come around and now you guys try to make amends. We do. And by the way, I mean, we may be passive aggressively let Dwight win the raffle, but you stole our power cord and hid it in a plant. I know I was about to say you guys fake the raffle. And I'm shocked by that. How could you? But I full on stole the cable and hit it in a plant. Yes, you sabotaged our karaoke machine. Okay, so now the parties have merged and the karaoke machine has its cord.
引开的方式，通过走进你的派对，试图挖墙脚。哦天哪，塑料女孩（Mean Girls）。我当时还很天真地觉得，干得漂亮，德怀特。我是说，我不觉得他赢了抽奖。我的看法是，这是帕姆和卡伦的一个“塑料女孩”时刻。但你让卡伦回心转意了，现在你们试图弥补过失。我们确实这么做了。顺便说一句，我是说，我们可能被动攻击地让德怀特赢了抽奖，但你偷了我们的电源线并把它藏在了一株植物里。我知道，我正要说呢。你们伪造了抽奖。我对此感到震惊。你怎么能这样？但我可是光明正大地偷了线缆并把它藏在了一株植物里。是的，你破坏了我们的卡拉OK机。好了，现在两个派对合并了，卡拉OK机也有了线缆。
And we open with Andy and Michael singing your body as a wonderland. Michael is not sure which Waitress is his girlfriend here. So he's singing to both of them. So we talked a little bit with Jen about all the different songs that people sing for karaoke, but we did not touch on this one. And I have some really good trivia about it. Let's hear it. So we reached out to John Mayer to ask him if we could use his song, your body is a wonderland. And it was actually BJ Novak who reached out to him because BJ knew him knows their pals. He reached out to him and he was like, can we use this? And at first John Mayer was like, I don't think so. What? He told his friend, not happening. He was like, I don't think so. And he actually wrote about this on his blog.
开场是由安迪和迈克尔合唱《Your Body Is a Wonderland》。迈克尔在这里不确定哪个女服务员是他的女友。所以他在对她们俩唱歌。所以我们和珍稍微聊了一下大家在卡拉OK唱的不同歌曲，但我们没有触及这首。我有一些关于这首歌的绝佳八卦。说来听听。所以我们联系了约翰·梅尔，问他我们是否可以使用他的歌《Your Body Is a Wonderland》。实际上是BJ·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）联系他的，因为BJ认识他，他们是哥们儿。他联系了他，然后问，“我们能用这首歌吗？”起初约翰·梅尔的反应是，“我看不行。”什么？他告诉他的朋友，没门。他当时说，“我看不行。”他实际上在他的博客上写过这件事。
He was like, one of my favorite shows on television, the office wanted to use my song, your body is a wonderland in a scene for their Christmas episode. And he was like, now, I'm not making apologies for my work, but it's safe to say I don't get asked to use wonderland for strongman competitions and documentaries about aircraft carriers. I usually get asked so that people can goof on it. So I initially turned down the request. But after thinking about it, I decided to go for it, but with one stipulation. What was it? He wrote, I want a Dundee. So BJ presented him with a Dundee for tallest music dude. He is very tall. He's very tall. And then he agreed to let us use the song. Well, look, I get it. Andy and Michael are
他写道：“电视上我最喜欢的节目之一《办公室》想要在他们圣诞特辑的一个场景里使用我的歌《Your Body Is a Wonderland》。”他接着说：“现在，我并不是在为我的作品辩解，但可以肯定的是，从来没有人请求在强力男子大赛或航空母舰纪录片里使用《Wonderland》。人们请求用它通常是为了拿它开涮。所以我最初拒绝了这个请求。但在考虑过之后，我决定答应，但有一个条件。”什么条件？他写道：“我要一个邓迪奖（Dundee）。”于是BJ授予了他一个“最高音乐老兄（tallest music dude）”的邓迪奖。他确实非常高。他非常高。然后他同意让我们使用这首歌。好吧，听着，我明白。安迪和迈克尔在这一集里
being total idiots in this episode. And so do you want your song to be the song the two idiots picked, right? Right. But he agreed. And Angela, we have a very fun story about John Mayer. We danced at the Walk Hard premiere party with John Mayer. And you were very pregnant. Look, this is like true BFF friendship, because I did not feel like being in a dress or in any kind of fancy shoes. But this was a big premiere for you. And I was so excited to celebrate it. And then, of course, because you and I have to, we had to dance. Listen, I left the after party before 10 p.m. I was like, I'm out. But I was going to have one dance with my best friend at her big movie premiere. And John Mayer was on the dance floor. And he was dancing with someone. And I'll never
完全就是个白痴。所以你会想让你的歌成为两个白痴挑选的歌吗？对吧？但后来他同意了。而且，安吉拉，我们有一个关于约翰·梅尔的非常有趣的笑话。我们在《永不止步》（Walk Hard）首映派对上和约翰·梅尔跳过舞。而你当时正怀着大孕肚。看，这绝对是真爱闺蜜情，因为我当时一点也不想穿裙子或任何花哨的鞋子。但这可是你的重大首映。我太兴奋想要庆祝了。然后，当然，因为你和我必须跳舞。听着，我在晚上10点前就离开派对后场了。我当时想，我要撤了。但我必须在我的好朋友的重大电影首映礼上跟她跳一支舞。而约翰·梅尔当时就在舞池里。他正在和某人跳舞。我永远不会
forget he turned around. And I'm sure he was really surprised to see a huge pregnant woman like directly behind him. And he was like, oh, my gosh, he goes, you're so beautiful. And then he touched my belly and he said, blessings, blessings. I will never forget it. My belly was blessed by John Mayer. And John, thank you from us for letting us use your song. Yeah. And he said he still has his Dundee, by the way. He still has it. He better still have his Dundee. I have both of mine.
忘记他转过身来。我敢肯定他看到一个大肚子孕妇直接站在他身后时一定非常惊讶。他当时说，噢，天哪，他说，“你太漂亮了。”然后他摸了摸我的肚子并说道，“祝福，祝福。”我永远不会忘记。我的肚子被约翰·梅尔祝福过。约翰，感谢你允许我们使用你的歌。是的。而且他说他现在还留着他的邓迪奖呢。他依然留着呢。他最好还是留着他的邓迪奖。我两个都留着呢。
I have both of mine. So now we have the scene that where Michael is over with Roy and Kevin, and he's kind of trying to brag about his new girlfriend, but it's very clear that he doesn't know which one is Nikki. Right. Kevin and Roy are like, you don't know. You should know. Michael, you should know. This leads Michael to really spin out. He needs to figure out which woman is his girlfriend. So he goes into the kitchen and he does this whole elaborate bit where he's like, where's my girlfriend? Where is she? Is she in the refrigerator? And it's this such this awkward moment where finally Nikki says, Michael, you know where I am. I'm right here.
我俩的都留着。所以现在到了那个场景，迈克尔和罗伊以及凯文在一起，他试图吹嘘他的新女友，但很明显他根本不知道哪个是妮基。对。凯文和罗伊就像是，“你不知道。你本该知道的。迈克尔，你本该知道的。”这导致迈克尔彻底情绪失控。他必须弄清楚哪个女人是他的女友。所以他走进厨房，做了一整套夸张的举动，大喊着，“我的女友在哪儿？她在哪儿？她在冰箱里吗？”这是一个极其尴尬的时刻，最后妮基说，“迈克尔，你知道我在哪儿。我就在这儿。”
So then when Michael goes in for a hug, he takes out a pen and he marks Nikki's arm, because this is now how he's going to be able to determine which one of these women is his girlfriend. And Angela this moment really made me cringe. Yeah, it made me cringe too. I just don't think the storyline would have been written today. Yeah, I don't think so either. All right, well, let's get back to the party. It's going really well. Everyone's having a better time. Karen and Jim exchanged Bridget Jones diary and Jen told us a story about that. Yes. And Pam gives Toby a robe. Where's she got it? I don't know. Maybe it's her robe. That was a fan theory that Pam gives Toby her robe. I like that. Yeah. And that's when
于是当迈克尔上前拥抱时，他掏出一支笔，在妮基的手臂上做了一个记号，因为这就是他以后如何确定这些女人中哪一个是他的女友的方法。安吉拉，这一幕真的让我觉得脚趾抠地。对，也让我觉得脚趾抠地。我只是觉得这样的剧情线如果在今天肯定写不出来了。对，我也这么觉得。好吧，让我们回到派对上来。进展得很顺利。每个人都玩得更开心了。卡伦和吉姆交换了《布里奇特·琼斯日记》，珍跟我们讲了这个故事。是的。帕姆送给托比一件长袍。她是从哪儿弄来的？我不知道。也许那是她自己的长袍。有一个粉丝理论认为帕姆把自己的长袍送给了托比。我喜欢这个说法。是的。就在这时，
the waitresses decide to leave, though. She's like, you know what, this party kind of sucks. And we're going to take off. And Michael's like, no, don't go, don't go. She's like, I'm going to go. So, and that's when he invites her on a trip to Sandals Jamaica. It's all inclusive. He is determined to get someone to go on this trip. That is the third person in one day he is asked to go. He asked Carol, he asked Pam. And now he's asked Nikki, the waitress. Yeah. But she's like, no, I think I'm just going to take my bike and get out of here and get out of your lame party. I'm sorry. I really love that she takes the bike. Oh, I do too. She's like, I have this bike at least. Yeah. So Michael is devastated. Andy's on the couch with Jim. And Michael is really mopey.
女服务员们决定离开了，虽然。她就说，你知道吗，这个派对挺逊的。我们要闪人了。迈克尔就说，别走，别走。她说，我还是要走。所以，就在那时，他邀请她去牙买加桑代尔度假村（Sandals Jamaica）旅游。那里是一价全包的。他下定决心一定要找个人跟他去这次旅行。那是他一天之内第三个邀请去的人。他邀请了卡罗尔，他邀请了帕姆。现在他又邀请了妮基，这个女服务员。对。但她说，不，我想我还是骑上我的自行车离开这儿吧，离开你这个逊毙了的派对。抱歉。我真的很喜欢她骑着自行车离开。哦，我也一样。她就像是，至少我还有这辆自行车。是的。所以迈克尔心碎欲绝。安迪和吉姆坐在沙发上，迈克尔非常沮丧。
He's like, she was the one. She was my true love and she's gone. And Jim is like, you barely knew her. You knew her for three hours. She's not the one. She was a rebound. And Michael's like, oh my God, a rebound. And Jim's like, yeah. And he goes on to say, which don't get me wrong, can be a great distraction. But when it's over, you're left thinking about the girl you really like, the one who broke your heart. And Jim is, I mean, we know who Jim's talking about in that moment. He's talking about him and Pam. And he's basically saying, Karen's a rebound, just like Nikki was a rebound. Yeah. But all Michael hears is that he's had a rebound and he's, he's super excited. Yeah. But Jim, we hear you. We hear you, Jim. We hear you. You love Pam. We
他说，她就是那个人。她就是我的真爱，而她走了。吉姆就说，你根本不了解她。你才认识她三个小时。她才不是那个真爱。她只是个替代品（rebound）。迈克尔就说，噢，天哪，替代品？吉姆说，对啊。他接着说道，别误会我，替代品确实能起到很好的转移注意力作用。但当它结束时，你会发现自己留下来满脑子想的还是那个你真正喜欢的女孩，那个伤了你心的女孩。吉姆在那个时刻，我是说，我们知道吉姆说的是谁。他说的是他和帕姆。他基本上是在说，卡伦是个替代品，就像妮基是个替代品一样。对。但迈克尔听到的只是他有过一个替代品，他超级兴奋。对。但吉姆，我们听到了。我们听到了，吉姆。我们听到了。你爱帕姆。我们
hear you. Now, Angela, we need to discuss Little Drummer Boy. Okay. We had a fan question from Amanda Gervais. Hmm. Hey, spelled differently than Ricky Gervais. But she wants to know, how was it decided that Dwight should hold the microphone for Angela? I found this choice really interesting because they don't want to look like they're dating. But this was kind of the first impression that they gave of interacting in a personal way in front of the entire office. Well, here's, here's my story. I was terrified to sing this song in front of everyone. I do not like singing in front of people. I, I just am not comfortable singing in front of people. It's, it's kind of crazy to my whole family because I will do improv. I'll do standup. I'll do crazy
听到了。现在，安吉拉，我们需要讨论一下《小鼓手男孩》（Little Drummer Boy）。好的。我们收到了来自阿曼达·热韦斯（Amanda Gervais）的粉丝提问。嗯。她的拼写和瑞奇·热韦斯（Ricky Gervais）不一样。但她想知道，剧组是怎么决定让德怀特为安吉拉拿话筒的？我觉得这个选择非常有趣，因为他们不想显得他们在谈恋爱。但这是他们在全办公室面前第一次给人留下进行私人互动的深刻印象。好吧，这是，这是我的故事。我当时害怕极了要在大家面前唱这首歌。我非常不喜欢在别人面前唱歌。我，我就是不习惯在别人面前唱歌。这对我全家人来说都有点不可思议，因为我会做即兴表演。我会做单口喜剧。我会做疯狂的
sketch comedy. I'll be all these weird characters. I have no fear ever getting up on stage. But if you want me to sing in front of people, it's like, I, I shut down like my brain computer is like, I can't do it. And there's been a few times in my career when I've had to do this. And this was the first time and I was terrified. And I'll never forget, I went up to Harold Ramis, who you guys, you know, we've said he was just a teddy bear. And I went up to him and I was like, here's a thing, Harold. I, um, I can't do it. I can't do it. I, I really just can't sing in front of people. And I can't do it. He really calmly put his hand on my back and looked at me and said, but you will. And I was like, Oh, God. Oh, no, I'm doing it. I am doing it. But Angela, I looked in the script
小品喜剧。我会扮演所有这些奇怪的角色。我在舞台上从来没有过任何恐惧。但如果你想让我在别人面前唱歌，就像是，我整个人会直接宕机，我的大脑计算机就像是，我做不到。而在我的职业生涯中，有几次我不得不这么做。这是第一次，当时我吓坏了。我永远不会忘记，我走到哈罗德·雷米斯（Harold Ramis）面前，你们大家，你知道的，我们说过他就像个大泰迪熊。我走到他面前说，情况是这样的，哈罗德。我，嗯，我做不到。我做不到。我，我真的就是不能在别人面前唱歌。我做不到。他真的很平静地把手放在我的背上，看着我说：“但你会的。”我当时就想，噢，天哪。噢，不，我要上台了。我要上了。但安吉拉，我在剧本里查过，
and this bit of Dwight holding the microphone is not in the script. So how did that happen? I shared with rain how scared I was, you know, we did a take or two where the microphone was on a stand, you know, and I'm standing holding my hands like in this very sort of like, I don't know, I'm, I'm clutching my hands and proper, very prim and proper clutching my hands in front of my chest. This was an idea that Jen had, you know, and so I'm standing like this because she was saying that she thought I should look like I'm in a very serious church choir stance or something, you know, so, okay. So I'm standing like that. And you guys, I was so nervous. I was digging my fingernails into the skin of my other hand. I had marks on my hands where I was just
德怀特拿话筒这个桥段根本不在剧本里。那这是怎么发生的？我跟雷恩分享了我有多害怕，你知道的，我们拍了一两遍，当时话筒是放在支架上的，你知道的，我站在那儿把双手紧紧扣在身前，做出一副非常类似，我不知道，我紧紧抓着手，端庄大方、非常正经地把双手扣在胸前。这是珍想出来的点子，你知道的，所以我当时就这么站着，因为她说她觉得我应该看起来像是在一个非常严肃的教堂唱诗班里站着什么的，你知道的，所以，好吧。所以我当时就这么站着。然后你们大家，我当时紧张得要命。我把手指甲死死掐进另一只手的手心里。我的手上都有印记，我当时就是
like, like death gripping myself. And after the first take, I showed rain my hands. I was like, I am so look what I'm doing. I'm so nervous. And rain, you know, listen, he just came through for me, you guys just came through for me. I was having a hard time. Even though I know the song, I'm so nervous and everyone was looking at me. I was having a hard time staying on beat. And he dropped, he took the microphone, he improvised this. He took the microphone, he dropped to his knee. And to help me like find the song, he's just started going bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump. And all of a sudden, I wasn't alone. Rain was with me. I mean, rain is six foot three. So when he's kneeling down, he's almost my height. It was
像这样，在死死地掐着自己。拍完第一条之后，我把手给雷恩看。我说，我真的，你看我在干什么。我太紧张了。然后雷恩，你知道的，听着，他真的是为了我挺身而出，伙计们，他真的是为了我挺身而出。我当时状态很艰难。尽管我知道这首歌，但我太紧张了，所有人都看着我。我很难踩准节拍。他突然走过来，拿过话筒，即兴发挥了这一幕。他拿过话筒，单膝跪地。为了帮我找到歌曲的节奏，他开始发出“嘭、嘭、嘭、嘭、嘭、嘭、嘭”的声音。突然之间，我不再是一个人了。雷恩跟我在一起。我是说，雷恩身高六尺三（约1米91）。所以当他单膝跪地时，他几乎跟我一样高。这就好像
like he was standing side by side with me. And then I could do it. And you see, if you watch ever so slightly, you see me smile. I'm not smiling because Angela loves Dwight. And she's getting to sing a Christmas song. I'm smiling because Angela Kinsey sees her friend, Rain Wilson, come through for her. Well, lady, I knew that story. And I was there when it happened. And when I watched this scene, I 100% saw that this was a scene between Angela Kinsey and Rain Wilson. Yeah. The way he's supporting you and the way you're smiling at him, it is so wonderful. And then it translates into this moment between Dwight and Angela that just enriches that relationship. What a wonderful, wonderful moment. It really is. Anyway, so rain, thank you so much
他正并肩跟我站在一起一样。然后我就能唱下去了。如果你仔细看的话，你会看到我笑了。我笑不是因为安吉拉爱德怀特，也不是因为她有机会唱一首圣诞歌。我笑是因为安吉拉·金斯利看到她的朋友雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）为她挺身而出。好吧，女士，我知道那个故事。当时我也在现场。当我看到这个场景时，我百分之百看出这是安吉拉·金斯利和雷恩·威尔逊之间的真实互动。是的。他支持你的方式以及你对他的微笑，太美妙了。然后这转化成了德怀特和安吉拉之间的一幕，极大地丰富了这段关系。多么美妙、多么精彩的时刻。真的。不管怎样，雷恩，非常感谢你用你的“嘭嘭声”为我挺身而出，帮我度过了那个场景。现在，在这一切发生的同时，安吉拉，
for coming through for me with your pump up a bums and getting me through that scene. Now, during all of this, Angela, Oscar and Gil walk into the party. What and he's like too soon. What brilliant timing, though. I mean, that was such a well written moment. Here he is making his return to work. You know, he's bringing his boyfriend. That's it. Oscar is back, right? And then he's Angela of all people, singing little drummer boy. And he just does a pivot. He's like, Nope, not happening. Also, during this in the background, we see Roy give Pam a Christmas gift. And we had some people right in to ask, what book did Roy get Pam for Christmas? Was it a really thoughtful gift?
奥斯卡和吉尔走进了派对。什么？而他就像是——太早了。不过，这时机简直太巧妙了。我是说，那是一个写得极好的时刻。他就在这里重返工作岗位。你知道的，他带着他的男朋友。就这样。奥斯卡回来了，对吧？然后他看到了安吉拉，竟然在唱《小鼓手男孩》。他直接来了个大反转。他就像是，不，这没法进行。另外，在此期间的背景中，我们看到罗伊送给帕姆一份圣诞礼物。我们有一些人写信来问，罗伊送给帕姆的究竟是什么书？这是一份非常周到的礼物吗？
This was asked by Juliet Wilson, Donna Miller, Celia Quiggle, Dimitra Lizu, Sarah Thorpe, Sarah Fletcher and Brooke Beagle. A lot of people want to know what the present was. You guys, it was an art book. It was a very thoughtful present. Roy is winning me over. He wasn't the best boyfriend fiance, but he's really trying. He's, you know, invested in how to learn how to gift wrap. And he's dressing nicer and he's getting in shape. And he is like, I'm going to buy you a thoughtful gift. And I know this was intentional. There was a part of this season where I thought Pam might be won over by Roy. And they weren't even sure in the writer's room, right? They hadn't decided. No, no, I had this whole conversation with Greg where I was
这是由朱丽叶·威尔逊（Juliet Wilson）、唐娜·米勒（Donna Miller）、西莉亚·奎格尔（Celia Quiggle）、迪米特拉·利祖（Dimitra Lizu）、萨拉·索普（Sarah Thorpe）、萨拉·弗莱彻（Sarah Fletcher）和布鲁克·比格尔（Brooke Beagle）提问的。很多人都想知道礼物到底是什么。伙计们，那是一本艺术书。这是一份非常周到的礼物。罗伊正在赢得我的芳心。他虽然不是最好的男朋友或未婚夫，但他真的很努力。他，你知道的，开始用心学习如何包装礼物了。而且他穿着更体面了，身材也练好了。他就像是，我要给你买一份周到的礼物。我知道这绝对是刻意安排的。在这个季度的某一段时间里，我曾以为帕姆可能会被罗伊重新赢得芳心。而且编剧室当时甚至都不确定，对吧？不，不，我跟格雷格有过这样一场完整的对话，我说，
like, Greg, wouldn't it be like a crazy, crazy thing if the real true love story is Pam and Roy? Like what if all this time, Jim is just a device that leads Pam to her real true love of Roy and Roy completely rehabilitates himself. And that's the love story of the office. It would blow people's minds. And Greg was kind of like, yeah, I hear what you're saying. I also think it's going to be Jim and Pam. But I was like, I'm just saying, if we really want to shock people, maybe it's Pam and Roy. Well, there and he was like, yeah, I don't know. There are people listening right now and are like, no. Oh, I know instead of jam fans, there would have been poi fans, poi fans. Ram fan. Ram fans. Well, I ultimately, I do believe that it was always going to be Jim and Pam,
“格雷格，如果真正的真爱故事其实是帕姆和罗伊，难道不是一件疯狂到极点的精神错乱的事吗？如果这一切背后，吉姆其实只是一个把帕姆引向她真正的真爱罗伊的工具，而且罗伊彻底改过自新了呢？那才是办公室的爱情故事。”这会惊掉所有人的下巴的。而格雷格当时的反应大概是，“嗯，我懂你的意思。但我还是觉得最终会是吉姆和帕姆。”但我当时说，“我只是随口说说，如果我们真的想震惊所有人，也许该是帕姆和罗伊。”好吧，当时他大概觉得，嗯，我不知道。现在肯定有正在收听的人在想，不。哦，我懂的，比起“杰姆（Jam）”粉丝，当时肯定会有“罗帕（Roy-Pam）”粉丝，简称罗帕粉丝。罗姆粉丝。
but we had a break and pause. We had a moment, I think partially because David Denman's performance, we were all a little bit falling in love with Roy right now. Yeah. Yeah, he did a great job. I think it was such an excellent foil to see Roy step it up, you know. And I think that needed to happen. I think Mindy sort of touched on that when she was a guest that like they, we needed to see Roy like really make a go of it. Yeah. Well, I want to say something. What's up with Jim? Jim clocks this through the window. And then all of a sudden he's like, hey, Pam, I want to do your CIA joke. Oh, do you Jim? You do. Interesting timing. Well, that you're suddenly invested in the CIA joke. Why couldn't he have just left well enough alone? Well,
罗姆（Ram）粉丝。好吧，最终，我确实相信结局一直都会是吉姆和帕姆，但我们当时有过一个停顿和暂停。我们有过一个时刻，部分原因可能是因为大卫·邓曼（David Denman）的精彩表演，我们当时其实都有点爱上罗伊了。是的。是的，他演得太棒了。我觉得看到罗伊奋起直追，这是一个非常绝佳的对照（foil），你知道的。而且我觉得这是必须发生的。我觉得明迪作为嘉宾时稍微提到了这一点，那就是我们，我们需要看到罗伊真正去放手一搏。嗯。好吧，我想说一件事。吉姆这是怎么了？吉姆透过窗户注意到了这一幕。然后突然之间他说，“嘿，帕姆，我想跟你一起讲那个CIA的笑话。”哦，是吗，吉姆？你想了。这时间点真有意思。
Pam was delighted. It literally saved the day for her. Yeah, she was thrilled. And it's very fun. They decide that they're going to tell Dwight that a helicopter will be picking him up. And he goes up to the roof. And then they play that final prank on him. I know. And then he throws his phone off the roof. Dwight. Amazing. Dwight, come on, buddy. Well, we can't end this episode without the major cliffhanger, which is that we spot Michael on the phone in his office inviting someone, a fourth person to Jamaica. And they say yes. And the look on his face, he's like, oh, okay. Like, oh my God. But who he has called, we don't know, it will be revealed next week. And back from vacation. I remember at the table read for this, when he read that last
好吧，你突然对这个CIA笑话上心了。他为什么就不能顺其自然、别去管它呢？嗯，帕姆可高兴坏了。这简直可以说是拯救了她的一天。是的，她当时欣喜若狂。而且这非常有趣。他们决定告诉德怀特会有一架直升机去接他。然后他上了屋顶。接着他们对他开了那个最终的恶作剧。我知道。然后他把手机从屋顶上扔了下去。德怀特。太绝了。德怀特，拜托，老兄。好了，我们不能在没有那个重大悬念的情况下结束这一集，那就是我们发现迈克尔在办公室里打电话，邀请了第四个人去牙买加。而且对方答应了。他脸上的表情，就像是，噢，好吧。就像是，噢，天哪。但究竟是谁被他打了电话，我们还不得而知，这将在下周揭晓。而且度假归来。我记得当时在这集的剧本围读会上，当他念出最后
line, there was such a buzz in the room. They're like, whoa, we know who it is. We know. But you guys know. And next week, we'll talk all about it. Well, that's it. We had a Benihana Christmas. We had awesome guests. Thank you, Rashida. Thank you, Jen. And thanks, you guys for listening. Yeah, we'll see you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一句台词时，房间里简直一片沸腾。大家都说，“哇，我们知道是谁了。我们知道。”但你们大家都知道。而下周，我们会把这一切聊个底朝天。好吧，就这样。我们度过了一个贝尼哈纳的圣诞节。我们有棒极了的嘉宾。谢谢你，拉什达。谢谢你，珍。谢谢你们大家的收听。是的，我们下周见。拜拜。感谢收听《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。